londres et on va suivre le match la fin
du match le dénouement du match qui
oppose dingli rennes à maxime vachier
lagrave le joueur français qui pourrait
terminer une troisième fois
deuxième du grand duché ce tour on
n'espère pas bien évidemment mais mais
c'est plus qu'une possibilité puisqu'il
est mené au score pour le moment 9 à 3
bon il ya encore les parties rapides
avec les victoires à quatre points à
venir donc on peut être en droit
d'imaginer que que le français a une
chance de revenir
il est bon en rapide il est bon en blitz
et ma foi
le match est loin loin loin d'être pliée
on va se faire on va se faire plaisir à
suivre à suivre cette rencontre en
intégralité j'ai envie de dire alors oui
et non dans le sens où une fois que le
match sera plié nous on partira donc si
jamais ding gagne mathématiquement le
match on restera pas pour les parties
amicales
on va simplement se concentrer sur sur
les parties à enjeu est donc j'ai la
petite j'habite motifs qui me dit qu'on
est bien en live de partout
je vérifie juste comme d'habitude le
début il ya mathieu qui va arriver je
lance je lance ses lives jeu lens lille
arrive en solo entre guillemets temps de
faire un peu tout la technique et puis
mathieu qui va qui va qui va très vite
arriver
narce en direct sur twitter en direct
sur youtube écouter on est bien de
partout c'est la bonne nouvelle
salut qu'à sa est toujours au rendez
vous bien sûr il faut que j'enlève mes
motifs faut que les notifs salue à cet
échec est toujours en place 9 3 suprême
ntm représente 6,6 salut à raphaël
stahly dans le chatt salue ton salut les
tontons crois tu viens un vrai c'était
sur youtube juste du coup ça lui à
jérôme trier aussi je rappeler les deux
cha des deux côtés c'est j'ai envie de
te dire et c'est du duplex faut faire
9,9 en fait ouais non il dommage que la
victoire sera pas de point il aurait pu
faire il aurait fallu qu'ils aient 9,2
9,3 9,4 9,5 7 5 7 7 7 8 pour ceux qui se
rappellent de l'album de rohff celle
d'art oissel darrois non personne
connaît ça paraît d'ailleurs que moi qui
connais ça c'est pas possible c'est pas
possible pour être le seul à écouter sa
tête je vais fermer la porte et je vais
en profiter
tu connais sefyu 30 si si tu connais non
ça avec des gens qui connaissent qu'ils
connaissent à pas celle d'awad faut
quand même écouté pas mal de rap pour
pourquoi être cette musique en plus
c'était c'était la traque bonus de
l'album c'était quoi déjà comme un album
la vie avant la mort c'était la vie
avant la mort cet album voyez c'est
rohff qui a sorti c'est la haye sway
seles toutes mes rêves frappe tu connais
ça tu as des bonnes ref en rap
ouais ça 2004 c'est un bel album non
avant avant avant ça doit dater
ça doit dater 2000 trop 2002 2003 je
pense
et je pense que je pense c'est sur
l'album la vie avant la mort salut david
qui salue l'élite aussi bas c'est beau
c'est vous attendez je vais essayer de
faire un truc très technique je vais
prendre mathieu bon ça s'appelle
technique mais je vais essayer de faire
faire un thé matcha ma femme attendait
les mecs donc là j'appelle mathieu pour
le récupérer et je vais lancer un truc
très technique donc là là attention
l'élite
salut mathieu écoute ça va très bien on
est en train d'essayer de faire un truc
très technique mathieu je vais essayer
de faire faire un thé matcha ma femme
d'un coup un thé matcha un match à
l'école c'est un thé c'est un thé de
qualité japonaise et je peux te dire que
là on est chauds moi j'ai payé le cf
juste avant de savoir j'ai payé aussi
non scellées ferait sens nous voilà tu
vois donc llena à ton truc très critique
qu'est ce que tu veux nous faire un thé
matcha ouais alors les n'a dit oui on n
y en a ce sera pour un millier de
personnes à peu près ça les parties bon
voilà du coup et mathieu on est bien
comment tu te sens ça va ça va j'ai mis
une nouvelle chemise qui va que mon
canapé derrière ça allait compliquer 1
ap et bordeaux 1 il sert à rien mais bon
c'est mon ancien canapé valeur affective
je garde ouais canapé rouge bordeaux qui
a une certaine valeur du coup tu me mets
le partage ouais je te mets de partage
je te mets le partage
je ferme tout on est là on est on sait
bien mis et a réussi à monter des
meubles alors ou pas ça en est où stx et
j'ai fini les meubles sont montées balle
pas tous mes sauts je voulais monter la
sauce
je suis un match nul 1 1 chez nulle part
de l'inde
mais ça ça veut dire qu'on va pouvoir
revenir chez toi [ __ ] la merde avec
ces nouveaux bugs quoi mon frère est pas
encore tout mais ouais bientôt je pense
l'objectif c'est que tout soit prêt pour
fin d'année pour pour le petit qui
arrive pas ouais enfin
non je me suis fixé la date raffin
daneshjou se soucier mais vous êtes tous
en train de faire des gamins parce que
ce matin j'avais les courts de tennis
mon prof son gamin est né il ya une
semaine toi toi ça va arriver
je suis un peu impatient tu vois dans
notre ciel des gens demande de parler
d'échec t il son show si vous jouez les
mêmes versions
[Musique]
enfin c'est pour toi la question moi je
suis qui je suis condamné yves borgeaud
c4 mais peut-être pas exactement la même
parce que l'autre c'est sûr qu'il a
regardé maxime oui bah oui alors c'est
etienne joue en bundle a joué ce matin
donc c'est passé simple mais il ya
peut-être
il ya peut-être d'autres français qui
est de maxime bon c'est pas trouvé hier
soir je sais qu'ils ont faim reste aussi
c'est avec un pote à moi qui m'a appelé
tout à l'heure comme des envies de
manger ensemble mais ça à maxime il
était à l était pas trop affecté à notre
mon pote ça a l'air d'aller
l'autre a bien jeu en fait juste faute
peut pas faire grand chose mais fut bien
mais la partie était vraiment belle
vraiment bien j'ai vraiment envie
d'aller voir notre vidéo résumé des il
est vraiment allé voir le résumé non non
je conseille aux gens de chat s'ils
n'ont pas encore eu à les gens du chat
très bas il est non mais là ils ont un
bon succès les résumés que qu'on fait
ensemble mathieu je vois que les gens
restent sur la vidéo ils partent pas en
fait c'est géant indien un petit truc
avec les cours pour voir si les gens
partent mais les gens ne parlent pas ils
restent en fait c'est qu'ils sont là les
yeux rivés sur l'écran et ils se disent
et donc du coup tu as vu en rapide
maxime de nouveau numéro un mondial en
fait il est passé devant
en magnus à cause du match de l'autre
jour et ding et 3e camara mais c'est en
blitz ce que le bât blesse pour le
chinois wang jing et quatrième le
français 13e
parce que tu es le france a aidé à 200
points et un armement
oui mais bon on va fouiller c'est à
cause de ce classement bleed ce qui veut
rien dire
ça va quand même quand tu vois que senna
carlson en tête pas non plus
complètement absents non meding
maintenant je prends ça va juste hyper
équilibré mais on pense qu'il est
meilleur en bis mais j'ai franchement ça
m'intéresse de voir ce qu'ils vont faire
tu donnes combien de pourcentage de
chance pour la remontée tada du joueur
français
je donnerai combien moi je donne 20% de
chance on allait au moins 30
donc la remonte à da est possible non
mais par exemple tcc genre compte il
peut finir à plusieurs produits gagne
mais ça suffit pas mais ça ne suffit pas
+ 2 ouais si ces deux envie de ça suffit
pas en revanche non mais s'il gagne une
rapide je pense qu'il se remet à 50 50
franchement si si gagne un ennemi en
demies en rapide il est bien là il me
revient à deux points il revient un
blitz après le chinois il va il va
craquer non bah on espère des sens de ta
muraille j'ai envie de dire la matinée
2% après un rapide non ça va être un
beau match il ya moyen de l'enjeu et où
wayne on en vint entre 20 et 30 % ça va
quand même on est français au bout d'un
moment la confiance revient en théorie
comme dirait hicham c'est une chanson
ait où il touche pas tous ces mariages
avec ça c'est quoi les clébards bien
joué pas mieux jouer peut-être pas
forcément bien joué mais mieux jouer son
adversaire jouer vite et bien ça ultime
je t'avais dit la fameuse phrase de
maxime masi ont fait des blitz dans un
bar un un peu tard et un peu alcoolisé à
montpellier et il me sort mon match il
faut qu'ils décident studio vite soit tu
joues bien latifa aucun des deux
aa c'est une belle punchlines et faire
les deux en même temps je n'étais pas
capable a évoqué j'avais dû en prendre
une ou deux mais j'avais pris celle ci
joue avec un handicap de temps normal
alors il ya barbares lancé ma qui lui
dit je pense que le jeu prophylaxie du
chinois est plus difficile à mettre en
place en rapide et beats c'est vrai nom
mais parme son idée de tout vouloir tout
contrôler seulement de nombreux calculs
bah oui c'est beaucoup plus dur donc
j'ai reconnu non mais j'allais dire je
suis encore sur le cul coule sur le cul
de la partie d'hier en fait les gens ont
appris la prophylaxie ta ouais c'est une
chose qu'on connaît depuis bien
longtemps mathieu j'avais fait un stage
avec jour skis et j'avais une journée
sur la prophylaxie venons en à peine 1
c'est un art difficile parce que trop de
prophylaxie tu la prophylaxie mais pas
assez c'est dommage aussi c'est très
difficile à gérer comme comme ça mais
dans les conseils qu'on peut donner à
l'auditeur même mon joueur en général
que je donne à mes élèves
il faut toujours penser à ce que fait
t'on adversaires et des fois mais jusque
quand tu vois que ton adversaire fait de
la merde laisse le faire danser qu'elle
ne part pas mais par contre quand on
voit qu'il a une bonne idée bah c'est
pas bête de l'appareil avant même la
passe mais c'est du bon sens mais
souvent on pense trop à ce qu'on fait
nous on pense pas forcément à ce après
après 2,7 à défaut des amateurs qui font
toujours à 3 et h3 dans toutes les
parties pour éviter fou g4g 4 pb 4 pb 4
faut pas trop le faire non plus quoi
faut avoir la bonne dose de prophylaxie
mais pensez à ce que vous sert vraiment
leurs adversaires ces deux ans à mon
conseil est pas causés chaque d'ailleurs
c'est un conseil universel même pour les
meubles pense ce qui a voulu faire le
mec me réjouis de un moment je me suis
posée sur mon canapé en fait j'ai essayé
de réfléchir et j'ai trouvé le problème
deux fois ça m'a fait ça et j'enrage et
trouver le prendre le lendemain c'est
qu'en fait j'ai essayé de comprendre
comment ça marche et est pourquoi j
arrivais pas et j'ai compté donc tu as
utilisé les échecs pour monter des
meubles davis
et c'est un truc le classement pour moi
a fait dévisser une davis bon bah oui
pourquoi
ouais ouais enfin c'est absurde mais il
doit y avoir une raison
c'est ça non merrill et du coup j'ai
compris ben moi j'ai un peu galéré pour
pour en fait la dernière étagères que
j'ai monté les tailleurs de ma chambre
en fait je les mâles montée du coup elle
est tombée il ya tout qui s'est pété et
puis je vais remonter une deuxième fois
mais mais mais elle est à moitié cassé
en fait pourquoi mon adversaire bien
jusqu'où oui oui il faut se poser la
question que votre art son adversaire
quand le coup est bien sûr mais
étonnamment vlady montré pas mal de
parties qui va contrôler étaient
ensemble et il considère que tu as
énormément de joueurs qui même à très
haut niveau qui comprennent pas les
plans de leurs adversaires genre même il
montrait des parties de mec à 2006 50
2007 et je réalise en fait la tuerie la
part compris le plan mais moi j'en ai
plein d'exemples 1,2 des fois tu gagnes
pas forcément fin j'ai des parties super
que je monte dans mes copains des
parties yvonne choqué en fait c'est pas
que ce qui fait c'est mieux qu'un autre
coup mais juste il a eu l'idée et son
adversaire s'il avait vu sur d'autres
qui auraient perdu le procès qu'il ne
voit pas donc cherché une idée même si
si dans les positions égale pas c'est
très important et par mon ami c'est très
forts pour ça oui oui mais il te force à
trouver les bons coups à défendre a
renvoyé la balle un coup de plus comme
les autres commodités mais wayne en
place mais ses parents que mam et
c'était typique l'exemple des joueurs
qui voyait pas les idées adverse après
ce que c'est pas par fainéantise ou
qu'ils sont fous un peu il est dans son
trip et même quand on suivait aussi en
assure un peu ensemble c'est le
championnat d'europe rapide féminin avec
la ddt et ils montraient pleins de
partis ouais il ya des parties fait et
médical coutu jour et où moi je trouve
le bon coup je souffre le quoi parce que
l'on sait que tu te fais insulter et la
fille joue pas le bon coup et mis en
fait tu vois là c'est juste que toi tu
as compris l'idée de l'adversaire elle
n'a pas vraiment cherché le délire quoi
imaginer que c'est arrivé très souvent
je lâche pas soit présent ouais nan mais
c'est marrant tu vois pas ce que c'est
un truc qu'on se dit qu'on t'apprend au
tout début déjà aux débutants c'est un
des premiers trucs que tu as envie de
leur apprendre c'est de voir ce que va
faire l'adversaire et même à haut niveau
c'est un défaut qui reste c'est bien de
travailler sur somme j'ai regardé ils
sont sur la scène c est ce qu on
commence à l'aider est-ce que c'est le
vrai coût est ce que c'est le coup du
gamin moi c'est leur coup ok donc tu
penses aussi grünfeld ouvre une fade
gumpel g3 g3 d'accord donc non mecs qui
jouent au foot avec ses six maintenant
ici ce qui peut retomber dans des genres
de destins diène destin guen non parce
qu'ils étaient cinq et je passais 6 est
d'accord dans le genre de slave un peu
hybride
c'est une grande fête ses six dessins et
des cd v parti qu'un pauvre kasparov
oui mais non je vois ce que c'était pour
essayer de faire un rapprochement avec
les auditeurs des maisons de négoce
mansour soder y avait je connais pas mal
à brooke
ouais mais là je sais 60 à 100 donc bord
il savoure el fahm aux auteurs du livre
des quatre quoi voilà et il l'a fait
aussi pour un créneau sur la ville et me
raconter on est en allemagne m'a raconté
que il est beau c'est pour chroniques et
il n'avait pas une idée sur les bonnes
feuilles
il n'arrivait pas à trouver y chercher
chercher chercher et me donnait foot et
un moment quelques mois après kra munich
joue les candidats et arrive à trouver
une idée et genre est il était choqué
qu'il avait trouvé encore un truc de cui
toi ouais et c'était sûr c'est d'une c6
dessins de parler il avait joué trois
cavaliers 2 qui était un nouveau concept
ok donc ça c'est intéressant
les noirs ont refusé de jouer b nonu
après dans ce tour de cou l'avantagent
c'est que si tu veux des cinq baies 5
est un bon coup les gens savent pas
forcément parce que puis on prend
quelques jours à 6
je me prends des six non non tu prends
pas mal à éviter des six ro rog
hélas hélas il ya un coup de fouet tu
fais qu'aller 17 tullins way et 7 points
kébé 6 et ça c'est un truc de fruits en
fait normalement dans ce système avec g3
fuji 2 sur le bingo qui est un bon
système
les blancs veulent jouer b3 dams et
d'autres biens et consolidées sauf que
ici sur dust2 le pion dessins qu'ils ont
prise ouais et surtout bien il ya foule
point que ça il faut être simplement à
c'est pour ça que tu as attendu c'est ça
et du coup c'est très intéressant où il
faut deux coups les blancs doivent 2e
cat
probablement et quelque chose comme vous
prend 1 6 3 et 6 4 kg 4 kg catch qu'elle
sait pas non plus la crise crise mais ça
va pour les noirs non l'idée c'est
d'aller vite y est la ligne la plus
dangereuse
donc c'est assez connus mais je pense
que l'idée de du chinois ces 2 juin elle
a fait des cinq hockey dont il avait
donné à ça c'est intéressant c'est ce
que je il n'a pas fait baisser en bout
ouais mais c'est ok benoni séance mme
bello 10 / g iii c'est censé être un
jour tourner un sens c'est un souk ou
très intéressant je parlais chinois jet
li chao était le spécialiste
ok l'idée c'est que kb24 on n'est pas
sûr à 100% de sa guérison prend on fait
dans ces deux chances et on veut faire
qu'il ya des jeux qui haïssent et quatre
non aux 4 4 avec la très à jouer pour
re5 les jeux au centre et ça j'étais pas
sûr à 100% que sergei et donc moi je
pensais qu'il fallait jouer plus tôt
avec ya eu 17 mais il a fait foi la
marque
ouais ouais ça existe aussi mais ne
forait 71.5 c'est le bon coup c'est le
cou à la mode software quatre médailles
auront à mon avis un maxime est pas un
expert 2 1 on va voir ce que le joueur
chinois répond tu penses qu'il a pu de
soissons la maxime m6 rappelle pas
exactement quelle idée de peut-être
caïds et 2 donc il veut sur conçurent
protéger la case de 4 et peut-être joué
aux quatre pour gagner un tempo sur le
fou pour expliquer revient la place dr
on fouette calanques locaux à la mode
ici avant les blancs les noirs jocaveil
aux quatre avec l'idée il ya peut-être
b2 faible mais en fait c'est assez
compliqué d'accord et prend 1,84 cas et
des deux est ici il ya deux courants pro
f 4 tours b 4 et le général tu perds la
qualité métal un pion mais c'est
compliqué donc du coup les noms raison
trouver autre chose et c'est l'idée de
dire autre chose d'ailleurs au coude
avant il a joué fouere 5 et son cash 4
pouces et 8 c'était une nulle rapide
quand il ya comme un coup dans un grand
prix d'accord il est fou de 4 d'ailleurs
et jouer aussi bien et je suis au fait
qu'un des deux pour comprendre la
différence avec tours ont ici à cavaler
h 1 il surfe autres on pourra attaquer
la qualité maintenant ou après c'est
juste pour expliquer et donc c'est pour
ça que dans la fusion la partie des jeux
c'est pour ça que je pense que cavaliers
des deux est bon parce que y'a plus qu'à
val et h5 pour toucher le fou et donc 4
va être jouable tranquillement et
médecins honnêtement j'avais pas vu ce
retour 1 en fait c'est un peu bizarre ce
que là tu as même pas qui a et 17 il ya
eu 4 fougerit 4 f 3.5 g4 n'ont donc
aucun des deux que ce qui est en tout
cas ça ça ça me met un petit coup de
pression à ding et que le cash flow fcf
des cats et tu reviendrais celle ci a
besoin
admettons ouais mais je jouais à kafka
plus tard 1la faut s kobe sein des cinq
passes par là je touche je touche la
tour ça assez de l'escrim là mathieu
mais là tu es dans dur mathieu blin
belloni on n'est jamais dans le nord où
un peu tout le temps tu choisis par les
dames c'est cette image et le choix
lâche toi je te ferai à 4 en fait je
fais x 4 août à petit feu les jeux fou
s'est vite ça va
ouais non je suis surpris mais pas assez
vite car ils s'inquiètent quand même en
fait a + b 5t dans le dur mathieu mais
on va voir si fait cavalier d2 et
peut-être sur cahier des deux il ya
quelque chose qu'on comprend pas de
toute façon on n'a pas la science un
patient n'avait la science infuse on
jouerait mathurin de toute façon il ya
peut-être du dom 17
il a fait cavalier d2 bah ouais pas de
spoil alors attendre un peu récupéré le
chat mais quelle idée de jouer mais vers
la russie a mais à surveiller sur la
bande c'est déjà quelque chose rsa etc
s'il veut déjà faire car il ya 6 ou
cavaliers h5
on ne renvoie au moins lui un cavalier
mvl il yal'idée deng 17 aussi avec pour
contrôler bessin et sera 4,91 qu'avaient
les assises pour la caisse des karaté
soir quatre peut-être faire x h x s'est
pas complètement butt
il ya 6 ou on nous annonce que la
turbine donne déjà un gros avantage
blanc pour moi personne c'était
d'autonomie une vie ce que leur dit d'un
entre +1 5 et + 2 donc ça prouve que
c'est donc non mais ça prouve qu'on dit
pas n'importe quoi est ce qu'on regarde
sans ordi donc ça fait plaisir de voir
dans le chat que voilà on est là quoi
donc
mais je pense que la ligne qu'on a dit
est complètement manquée mais mes
parents doivent à trouver d'égalité ben
euh 4 ça paraît vraiment être le coup
ici un idéal ou non en fait flop 5 il a
confondu ces surfeurs cap space on nous
dit alors dit plutôt mauvais pour jouer
les pollutions benoni à estaing dianor
c'est vrai mais quand ils donnent +18
+19 ça veut quand même dire un petit peu
quelque chose ouais c'est un truc contre
mais je crois que c'est ce que tu as dit
en fait à bien évaluer
il ya juste une femme sur les 17 cas et
ses quatre des cinq a pas l'air de
marcher vraiment grosse grosse erreur
grosse erreur de maximin quand même bon
ça c'est pour moi ce n'est rien de
culture ou de mémoire ou les deux
monnaies 2 ou 2 qui culture mémorable où
mémorial qui va comme on dit
tu vois là et qui dit pour avoir le
droit de commenter il faudrait que les
commentateurs soit plus fort que les
joueurs qui jouaient ce serait venue
serait jamais comment tu as magnus
pourrai jamais dire que magnus qui
pourrait commenter du coup avec les
commentateurs soit plus fort mais mais
pour le grand le fils fait cependant le
speech est féminin pardon parfois c'est
un peu difficile a commenté
pourquoi ben des fois ça arrive et que
les fjords cadre des trucs assez on
alain j'ai vu des trucs défaut c'est pas
beau
oui oui danser sur mer nazis en rien la
position fou 17 caisses et quatre des
cinq prises fuji cote parce qu'on est
vraiment un f3 nom que sa cadette 3
donne prends tu peux pas prendre des
cinq pieds de bêtises on comprend bien
geffray f4 prochain mathieu et âge j'ai
débarqué à prendre le 4 mai cette
emprise à temps il a joué quoi il a joué
fou j'écarte f3 qui font des cette crise
et 4 dames b8 arrive à faire flouer f4
fouet fuite à 4,1 propose cinq cavaliers
un chien était peut-être si si si
c'était mon idée mais je ne sais pas à
quel point ce fort n'ont pas l'air si tu
rentres tu prends un bain du projet 2
tom waits 2,8 retour des 8
oui ça va aller cavaliers b8 au cas où
en plus tu peux revenir le lendemain
mieux fait dans son palais bref quatre
fuites on devine les coûts déjà mathieu
a enfin un bon vous et sur b5
il fallait faire ça car d'abord aka
amérique as-tu fait kiev
[Musique]
après il faut pas oublier qu'il eut
cavaliers à 5 maintenant pour joe kay c6
et ouvrir la pause fait cavalier h5
cliquer et bécasses et du sol
tu veux faire cailler à 5 peut-être
logique 1 à 4 va super logique sur
cavaliers mathieu sur cash 5 ont fait
jeu parce que tu en penses
j'en fais peut-être fou des deux g4 on
vient au f4 wayne pour m'offrir des
blancs je pense que ça absolument
gagnant pour les blancs il est tombé 5
qui arrive
la seule bonne nouvelle c'est que notre
joueur a les noirs donc la hausse 5
c'est de l'eau car il ya 5
ding qui joue vite et franchement
j'aurais jauge et 4 font signe à
peut-être bien un truc j'ai quatre îles
menacées eu cinq cas aussi du quai v5
mais en fait un ces pollutions kébé 5
même si c'est un bon coup les blancs les
noirs vont simplifier des fois ça leur
fait du bien d'échanger une perte de
pièces g4g 4 avec l'idée de 5 ça a l'air
d'être forme sur 1,5 au pire tu fais h3c
un problème mais ça joue à toute blinde
là je comprends pas vraiment pourquoi
avoir deux caméras ça vaut ça joue
vraiment à toute blinde de mathieu bon
il disait j'ai ouais ouais ça joue trop
vite il reste plus de 20 minutes
ça joue beaucoup trop de points enfin
pour le moment c'est c'la démonta la
sela telle honte à dallas
bon après on espère que les inactifs
d'un chat non mais mathieu là c'est gras
place qui est en train d'arriver là on
est on est en train de on est en train
de se taire et de benoni et en
chaussettes
ouais c'est ça me rappelle mes benoni
fut tellement nul dans la baie de nice
et si je venais avec les noirs c'est à
peu près ça le résultat qua non mais un
mois je savais que sur tourcoing il faut
jouer un plan un cahier 17 à 6 c'est
après que je achi jessains kg qu'attaché
g5 je connais enfin s'il faut qu'il
connaisse pas vite quand c'est comment
tu expliques ça m'a tué à ce niveau là
de faire des erreurs comme celle là il
ya là pour moi c'est plus de
déconcentration de ce qui doit savoir
que fo fc software 4 il a dit jeudi à
hasparren badgers pourquoi j'ai pas
d'explication rationnelle impôts pour un
peu élargir le débat tu vois quand on
quand on a en parallèle battu t'avais
dit la même chose donc on va juste un
peu se répéter par rapport à un autre
style mais mais quand quand les joueurs
n'ont plus de seconde en com fait gris
choo qu'ils ont il se rappelle mieux des
coûts parce que parce que ceux qui les
travaillent et maintes fois quand un
second temps et que tu lis juste les
fichiers il ya des choses comme ça alors
il va s'en rappeler ci prend le temps où
quoi et qui se précipite pas mais c'est
moins ancré la connaissance aller -
encrés moins profondes
un prélat je pense aussi à défaut la
concentration là au moins l'âge de trop
vite non mais là je vais trop vite c'est
sûr mais géré si c'est toi qui as fais
tout ton fichier et tout c'est plus
facile à s'en rappeler non mais ce que
pour expliquer aux gens quand même à
l'ap
j'ai dit pouvait être qu'à traiter le
coup mais tu peux dormir le coup le coût
principal dans la base sur chercher le
nom de la partie
si ces caïds et 2,15 l'idée c'est de
jeux à 4 oui oui oui non mais c'est le
message avait même vu des partis comme
ça déjà j'ai même vu déjà ça mouille et
la théorie s'est assis sa cave cay et
dessert mais oui donc en réalité quand
il fait tout revend ils menacent un peu
4 et c'est pour ça du coup tu parlais du
cac valeo 4 qui était possible mais faut
être sain que ça fait aucun sens que tu
retournes dans la position avec deux
temps perdu oui puisque tous rangs ils
savent à son hôtel the way efficace que
j'ai expliqué ces glaces étaient
jouables parce que sauf qu'à y est les
deux à la phase de tourin son souk est
de deux gars qu'avaient les achats
qu'est le fou n'a pas de bonnes cases
ouais donc il a mélangé des variantes
mais pour moi ça va c'est l'explication
après peut-être qu'il connaît pas tout
mais je le conseille train pour aller
blanche ça vraiment pas bête et en plus
comme c'est pas principal les gens
connaissent pas forcément si mal que je
ne connais pas après j'en profite aussi
pour pour dire que tu es un théoricien
de premier plan et qu'en france même
même les meilleurs français te respecte
pour tes connaissances théoriques qui
sont tues tu fais partie des meilleurs
en france au niveau des ouvertures des
préparations tu es quand même nom mais
bien d'un message mais je repars avec
les joueurs vraiment quand tu dit
mathieu cornet tu vois des mecs de
premier plan ils disent l'ouverture tu
vois c'est pas fort l'a pas c'est quoi
ça va bien se passer et tu vois j'ai
déjà une grosse réputation et j'ai une
bonne culture
oui oui et puis tu as une grosse serait
plus tard fajjar oui mais tu as une
culture fin j'étais bon et à la
réputation d'être bon tout le monde le
sait quoi je parlais un peu mon point
fort on est d'accord
donc il a joué et s'il faut au 3 mai oui
j en fait c'est du maximin il gigote il
peut vraiment s'en sortir un ding a
montré dans les parties précédentes
mathieu qu'il avait un peu de mal à
finir maxime qu'il avait un peu peur un
peu plus être donc les noirs ans vaty il
aurait joué dix coups de suite ils
feraient soit 5 soit b6 acide des cinq
mais ça marcherait pas bien b6 acide
homme ccdh bessin un peu long il a joué
avec cinq mois il envoie ouais ça ne
peut pas marcher
ouais mais bon il tente
il tente son va-tout prise il veut
prendre du fou fou prend je pense qu'à
des quatre noms ou des trous t3
j'ironise est vrai nom mais tu as raison
ce validé ces fouilles dsk après le vin
c'est petit a g6 qui va être prise prise
tu as des x 3 x 3 damien de ou un petit
jeu bah non c'est peut-être pas si clair
en tout cas il fout le bordel
parce que prise gf sommes bien à la
limite pourquoi pas hein je pense que
d'un coup boom fois çi ce moment ouais
aller sur d'amd 8 stora fou prend et
qu'il prend des six diables
donc je pense à toi des prises kg 7 mai
bourdin il ya des 600 plaisir est ce que
je vais dire tu te fais touché des six
souhaitent donc donc tu peux pas rendre
non mais l'idée c'est clairement ça
c'est sûr matures c'est sûr que c'est ça
la position mais ouais ça me fait un peu
peur après il peut aussi ne pas prendre
les jeux fois çi ce tranquille
lakhal moment donc d'avant
tokyo 5 parfois parce que puis on prend
1,4 à l'aura de reprendre les chemins
mènent au pied droit
ouais nan t'as raison oui fois ci ça a
l'air d'être fort d'emprise prises qui
haïssez 2 il faut être sûr que j'ai
quelque chose mais je le vois pas on va
dire bion brand ouais mais tu as le
tourment pour tout reprend y avait des
preuves si on prend ouais mais je me
trouve un client gesat un ça va
non non il ya trop de matériaux pris
donc ça veut dire que x jeu se marchent
pas bien donc plutôt e f g 4
allez ça veut dire qu'ils menacent pas
grand chose ce qu'il ya un coût plus
utile
un petit coucou tout re 2 e et j'avais
proposé
c'est bizarre non il doit y avoir
d'autres teams tour de c'est pas mal
quand même non c'est pas con ça tu peux
doubler mais peut-être fou g7 au moins
le four viadana aussi claire j'y crois
pas du tout mais aussi joué contre nous
ça se passe très bien
si je veux contre toi au moins il serait
favori la maxime savent à quoi bon ok
sauf si je trouve un gain forcé après
point 900 et jack a surpris que ça
ferait pas retrouvé leur force et messi
a pas de gain forcé qui commence à
gigoter on sera juste ce propos ce
groupe
tu veux qu'on fait un petit switch sur
ma news peut être aller ouais en fait
ils réfléchissent enfin je peux voir le
début c'est vrai on lance on lance
rapide un hoquet bécade f6 et le coût
principal c5 ça va devenir un mode
normal non c'est ça qu'on veut plutôt
étroit et pour jouer un bluesman fun
mais là elle a décidé du un bain co non
même qu à l'envers je pensais que
c'était ok point mort
après magnus qui qui devrait remporter
le match sans trop de sans trop de
problèmes dont il a si l'aja six points
d'avance surtout quand rapide et
oublient de saulcy du coup on retourne
sur le français ouais mais les nantis
violent il a fait puis on prend fou
prend mais ok donc j'ai quatre fous des
trois prises prise prix g6 et je pense
avoir signé des fois je crois mon
intuition
sa poule et c'est adam toujours un petit
coup droit chemin après peut-être que
non ça fait chier calme prend peugeot 6
x 600 damesin ce que les noirs peuvent
essayer d'envoyer danse art r je voulais
c'est en voyant mais stationnaire d'anne
frank et ses deux dames de six ans ça va
être galère on va voir ce qu'il a joué
il a joué j'ai quatre coups des trois
monts pour l'instant on voit bien les
choses ce nom pourvu que ça dure vrai
pour le monde anticipe n'anticipe 6
passes on comprend ce que les joueurs
veulent jouer mais pas quand on aime
toujours ce qu'elle était et ce qu'il a
autre chose de faite que puis en train à
chaque cavalier bouge ça serait bizarre
ce qui est noir fric et 6,1 cavale et à
3 pour couvrir ces deux avec cavalli m6
mais il peut peut-être joué sur le fou
qui a plus de 4 mais je vois pas comment
il mais je vois pas donner vu le cavale
il est dur à déloger
à moins qu'il ya un truc concret avec
cavaliers à deux ça saute pas aux yeux
peut-être qu'à 3 qui avec 6 cas et à 2
ouais mais karim wade s
quand tu prends bekkat à la fin il ya
trois semaines je fois ci c'est bon tu
vas perdre un pion peut-être même un
même patient non mais ça c'est enfin je
sais pas visuellement je n'ai pas du
tout envie de faire ça non dans les
prises prise prise prises et ça ça
parait vraiment logique mais comme tu
disais ya du d'alger 2 il ya du foie
justicia du foie aussi celle du cavalier
e 4 un fou et six cavaliers 4
c'est-à-dire les menaces non médicaux
qui avait lieu 4 tout de suite
j'aurais t5 en l'air peut-être way pas
sûr pour ces 1 1%
voilà vous même ou tel que quelque 4
mars mais il a fait fouet fin on n'a pas
vu mais t'as vu encore une fois il est
vraiment en contrôle 1 c'est terrible il
faudrait faire un saut c'est si bon bref
tu mettais pions sur case blanche de
change de la pièce la plus active
adverse mais alors là c'est ce que
maxime pdc se faire [ __ ] en ckd pense
y pullulent plutôt prendre un enfant
est-ce que ça ce serait si mauvais
cavaliers fc bouaye fougères cinq tours
ok on fait la gueule donc ça c'est pas
une option donc fou prend un ff plus ou
moins forcé pour le ski le compte du roi
je pense que oui oui de toute façon son
roi au pire et reviendra en g2 mais au
moins il perd pas de temps avec la tour
donc si tu veux manger c'est terrible a
plus aucune case un nom qui coup de
foudre dans cavaliers 6 ouais je montre
justin tu te prends une focale avec la
est encore un truc là et cette case vrai
tu l'as pas pascal boor de vie ok et la
foule fils bongo peut pas jouer comme ça
tu y es bessin et si tu fais à 6,6
accueille des 6 à 5
mais les blancs pas grand monde ne me
lasse peut-être pour l'instant way to
reçu cela a commencé avec une menace que
des sites doit traîner gamin force
t'as pas tort tous réussissent va être
une menace est on doit je donne des vite
ici et peut-être même faire et peut-être
même prendre tu prends du cavaliere met
une tour en un an
ouais ah oui nos monnaies on est dans le
dur mais et c'est cette juge ig est un
peu gigote un peu tu semi gigote ouais
c'est pas fini fini
ils m'ont points maxime déjà dans le voc
c'est un peu ça mais en plus ou moins
honnêtement on avait l'impression ne
sera que de pire que çà mais c'est
toujours moche sais pas si on a une
quelqu'un qui me lâche une petite éval
par curiosité mais je pense que c'est
resté toujours aux alentours de 1 50
mais mais bon il tient à quoi ils
peuvent voter à plus d'un moment je
serai pas au moins huit frères j'ai cru
qu'il réfléchisse pour jouer cavalier 6
je regarde la caméra
jimmy la caméra en grand mois ils te
disent avec la dame en b 8 est très
active ainsi que la tour à 8,6 et un peu
les pièces fortes côté noir site web et
web
suis pas trop surpris c'est ce que
j'aurais dit ça baisse mais digne 30
contrôles c'est un peu l'impression que
ça donne
ouais ça s'est passé d'un peut-être d'un
monde les plus de 50 avec une position
un peu chaotique à +2 stable entre
guillemets les maxima fait qu'une erreur
c'est juste ils achètent tempo faut être
cinglé voiture est juste c'est pas cette
commission composée de cinq faisceaux
fouet après tout rien c'est juste pour
vous et les deux les blancs sont nuls
bon il a fait une erreur mais une grosse
erreur enfin j'ai envie de te dire il a
fait une double faute quoi c'est pas
normal
on nous propose dams et 8 pour aller
chercher le père pète mais je pense
qu'après pions prendre un match trois
dames g2 s'appelle gucci à peu près tout
ce que t'as pas deux échecs donc ouais
c'est un peu un peu un peu un peu short
donc cavalier fils comme on l'avait
prédit
il a joué il a joué way est fou g5
donc c'était un autre coup auquel
j'avais pensé mais je n'ai pas dis bon
évidemment c'était une autre option 1
sur la caméra
ça y est peut-être dame est alors je
sais moi de chasse comme ils ont fait
des efforts je sais pas comment ils ont
fait mais pour les pgm en fait ils font
un effort pour les rapides que ce soit
vraiment plus que le direct donc ça se
peut qu'on soit bien dans la veine du
management
il a joué face de cette fois il joue
hyper vie digne à la haye mais je vous
invite comme maxime ouais mais ma fille
mais on sait qu'ils ont trop vite mais
il joue à toute blinde mefou g5 pour
faire bouger cette fois fkt forcé fouet
fuite c'est bien joué quand même le
petit chacun essayait au niveau jeu de
jambes il est bon le fil un nom ça y est
bien là mais hier il a vraiment mis sur
le cul digne pour moi c'est une des
meilleures partie de l'année j'ai aussi
un petit plan h3 damage de voir un jeu
c'est joli mathieu après l'udc et des
trois mets délicats et d5 un futur pôle
fixe gvt est l'idole droit échanger des
contres des six secondes des simples je
pense que les blancs eux jugent que les
décisions du coup maxi fil des six
excuse moi ils filent des six alors à
tanger une petite vente a montré pour le
l'esthétisme tu vas voir la variante
elle va tu vas kiffer monte pas en train
de kiffer la variante franchement tu
kiffes labaye ça va non pas trop son nom
et noir oui je sais mais bon c'était
enfin qu aux actifs qu'elles pourraient
les six tours f8 ok donc roigé deux
candidats non il peut pas prendre des
106 et sur échec moi j'ai deux semble
être le coup le plus logique non tu
enlève ton roi de tous les problèmes tu
te protège d'ailleurs joué je voudrais
que tu as raison il joue vraiment envie
de ding russie les chinois à les mecs
jouent à toute blinde quoi ils sont très
énervés en fait qu'ils aient mais moi je
vois bien dan 17 pour aller faire du
quai franche et quatre non ouais c'est
vraiment un 6pool ait un j'ai
l'impression que tu as pas plus drôle il
sacré prendre soin de cette fois que la
b7 en l'air aussi un village où il donne
17 à la surprise générale et mais en
fait menace rien mais je me demandais si
toro si c'était possible qu'ils aient
prenez cinq prises d'un premier set ça
aurait du coup que je vous jamais eu
tellement peur de me prendre un chip aux
wem est d'ailleurs un truc comme d'hab
si c'est ça paraît bizarre ça ok je
souffre j'ai droit est fou j'ai trois
c'est bien joué mais dans le même style
qui hier il en paie prophylaxie conquis
à l'étranger 4 mai le jeu tour aux deux
ou peut-être tout réussit cependant
d'ailleurs qui est plus f4 ouais non ça
va être moche tour deux tours heures en
fait 1 5 ha sur g5 il veut quoi en fait
h4 non pardon je vais enfin est ce que
lui-même le souhaite
fait h4 non ça marche pas petit regret
peut-être un cookie pas ok je fais ça je
vais dame g5 ça pourrait être fort - et
puis on tend au joker
je vais prendre j'ai ici c'est vraiment
on n'en sait rien non tu as raison à
jouer peut-être d'alger 5 après si j'ai
cinq peut-être ce cavalier achètent
moins une menace un truc avec h car un
jour toi mais tu as raison h3c plus dans
l'esprit tapions sur cases blanches
toutes cases noires c'est plus solide et
quoi jean guérin
[Musique]
on va pas se mentir les chances de
maxime 130 familles s'amoindrir il a
besoin
hergé 5 la presse est ultra logique 1 km
h est allé faut jouer il va faire h4 non
regarde 47 c'est quand même horrible ses
katas matures je regarde et on pointe 3
le beau jeu ça va je crois à l'ancienne
un sens si tu mens l'a vu à tours ça
veut dire ouais je suis refroidie
non j'y voyais pas du tout mais pas
démonter et accueille pris une douche
écossaise du temps en temps tu as raison
tu as raison on est là pour le beau jeu
on n'est pas on n'est pas pleutre
mathieu évolué huit peut-être pourra
changer
ouais mais car il ya quatre et je pense
qu'ils te rebondi là-dessus wef ou des
quêtes et kg celle qui est maintenant ça
va c'est ce job ça dure
il ya des 115 ya des cinq en l'air mais
même cette finale n'ont qu'à y ses 620
ou des trois mêmes savoirs m'a vu pire
non mais c'est peut-être ma moquer ouais
c'est sa tête
et la fecq a valu huit allez allez pas
mal il enlève là ils activent au moins
ces retours à 8 et 6 prend tout reprend
franchement je commence à dire c'est pas
si grave d'un médecin qui va arriver
s'en fout des quatre faut pas oublier
que le québec est à près de 9,5 tapis et
c'est deux caïds et 3 allez on y croit
franchement on n'y croit alors est ce
qui peut faire tours 6 des fois tu as dh
4 maintenant ouais c'est pas faux au
fond f4 sourire c'est une carte bancaire
tu as des caïds et 3 1 et suivant ses
comptes ans il fait cavalier huit tours
touré huit tours et 8 fou prend h 4 à
face au natif ouais mais bon ça peut
être un peu de jeu il a fait tour 6 h
quatre noms mais mathieu aujourd'hui
franchement qui peut s'asseoir à notre
table match non franchement on n'est pas
mince franchement on en rêverait arnaud
fake on trouve tous les coups mathieu
non mais je pense tu rentres là dedans
et toutes actives et tu tu pêches en
outre le quoi tu sais que dans la ligne
ont pu interpeller h trois échecs à 8
tours prend h trois échecs droits
atteint 3,8 web peut-être ça va ça je
pense que ça c'est quasiment ok ben
écoute il est en train de nous faire un
tour de magie la maxime qu'est ce qu'il
est bon pour ça c'est complètement fou
et kate il doit y avoir quelque chose
bon je sais pas quoi on sent que la
tactique est de notre côté il faut être
quatre ça sent la tactique notre côté
rennais jusqu'à et détroit donc des
trous bref cap yahia ziani il y avait
six villes
il faut être 400 le seul coup par contre
ce que cavalier huit tours 8
avec h3 s'assemblent ça semble plutôt
cool pour nous tu as honte diffus f4
seul coup ouais ouais maxime light en un
joli piège midi ludique de large
c'est quoi le piège pas le truc avec h3
assez correct ce qu'on a dit mais
apparemment est donc faux f4 et le seul
coup au kef wes cates un jeu trois fois
et fiat on sait pas par contre je crois
c'est un coup quand même vachement la
paire de rois g3 tu peux pas avoir peur
de son patois bas le roi montrent un g13
g4 le pion tu as enfin fou non mais je
pense que je vais aller mathieu qui
lâche une info sur ce live
victoire de maxime allais l'info est
lâché yat j'arrive pas à faire marcher
tout reprend mais peut-être que ça
marche
je pense qu'il va faire un choix
intermédiaire c'est un super agent de
tête de bong et prend des 5 c'est ça
l'idée ne nous est pas un dessin qui
attend son tour prend et qui a aidé 5 kg
du cavalier fils à la fin même avec
l'orangé trois surfe ou cinq jurys
cavale et 6 échecs quand même mélodie
dit on attend ding en ce sens un mathieu
sévin 6 ah non non mais oui je l'aï
d'ailleurs dit qu'il prendrait cinq
résidents points 8 seront prises
tours de roue en f1 serait plutôt
partions achat d'un mach 3
5h et peut-être maintenant dans mais je
sais pas faire ce qui a été joué il a
joué fouet 4h trois rois g3 et la lys
il veut je donne tu prends un faux seins
le sac et la donne non il y aura quatre
ou six tours prend il ajout de 9 5 5 il
a fait fou prend des six ok donc là il a
dû vendre un truc un coup c'est le parti
c'est la partie qui menace qui prend des
cinq tours j'ai l'impression qu'on est
en train de manquer de gaz parce que là
ils menacent tout ranger si ce n'est le
chinois chez pas assez tendue mathieu
sauvegarde et de 9,7 pas mais ça j'ai
peur de f4 et après tout recettes qui
arrive mathieu ouais ils auraient raté
un truc ou quoi ils disposent donc non
je crois je crois que juste jeudi mais
en train de la ligne numéro un gay c'est
foutu on nous dit sky mobile rate rien
dingle apparemment et il te fait il te
féline numéro l'ordi dans la gueule en
rapide quoi parle ce genre ok mais faut
arrêter un moment donné enfin un fou y
en a marre
tous rêvent fuite fou prend 1 et
software suite d'un coup elle fait suite
au rejet si j'ai peur d'aimer matinée à
13 minutes c'est un an l'institut a elle
fait drôle à shanghai tandis que 10
minutes en chaîne que de la première
ligne de l'ordif un genre grand faut
qu'il arrête il joue vraiment bien il
est vraiment impressionnant
mais bon
après ça s'est joué dans l'ouverture
mathieu ou un buzz sport go finir je
pense
t'as pas vraiment de menaces ok tu
restes tu as tout rejet si je pense
quand même pas à quel point ça gagne
mais j'ai l'impression qu'avec les les
blindes s ouais tu as peut-être pas ça
qui tuerait toute cette f4 et faire
quelque chose vous france et 5 aussi
français 5e rang des cinq tours des six
manqué ouais je sais pas ce que tu me
l'as en fait tu penses que josias ne
sais pas non plus peut-être qu'il va
jouer six fois j'y ai pensé mais juste
se passer de blizzard donné j'ai six
mois j'avais peur de tourner ici se
croient qu'avec par n'importe où wesh 7
on va dire hachette qui l'entourent là
c'est ça qui embêtait sage avait peu vu
bien fait tourner ses pouvoir être quant
à l'autre tour qui rentre sur la 6e j'ai
l'impression que ça va bien se passer
quoi ou pas ouais bah en fait un peu
comme m us et t'inquiète pas ça va bien
se passer tu as c'est ça le futur ça va
mal se passer
je pense que tu es dans le dur quant à
la tour e qui arrive en russie sans
perdre un set 6 jeux voient même pas un
coup en fait je vois pas l'ombre d'une
idée pour le joueur français
ben j'ai trouvé peut-être un piège il
commence et le marché saint jean des
maps est interdite
on nous dit abandon abandon peut être un
coup ici rêve mon avis
là c'est la démonte adar c'est là c'est
la douche froide ni de vendre les
meubles sont en diminution lapin donc
non c'est pas nous jugeons haut de page
allez je vais militer valent pour se
faire peur ouais ok bon d'accord puis
suit trois sets joués lot 6 1 quelle
heure la deuxième game on vient filmer
ce sera à 16h30 je pense c'est une heure
et demie après la première
1h30 bah oui pas après la fin à une
heure et demie après le début donc si ça
a commencé à 15 heures ça fera 16h30
sinon c'est comme ça ça se termine à
canada l'arnaqué l'heure prévue et après
ça ajoute une heure et demie après une
heure et demi donc 18 heures et après
toutes les demi heures
mais bon on ira peut-être pas jusqu'à la
dernière si même pas la dernière phrase
enter the way si maxime est encore en
vie puisque nous on regardera pas les
partis qui joue pas entre guillemets
c'est vrai il a eu les nerfs mais j'ai
l'impression qu'il était revenu un
moment
ouais mais après s'il te disent ils ont
ré avec l'ordi et qu'il était toujours
en contrôle ce qui est toujours en
contrôle 1 et il faut sortir le coup de
la touillette il va y avoir tour à tour
à chis tour j'ai six tours h7 est à la
dame ou un truc comme ça va super
portier de donc atteint il faut prendre
la fuite il a pris à eux six prix aussi
ce prix en fuite
do you know me deux autres choisis
tokens f4 il veut faire dame de damas
cinq coups à l'abandon
abandon pris le partie ouest et est
salah elle va finir elle n'a pas finir
sur youtube la finir sur sur les
concurrents de youtube - de plus de plus
de 18 kwh à mon avis à mon avis c'était
vraiment c'est la démonte à d'art public
et les suberaies bon ce parent j'ai
l'impression que c'est un jeu de retour
contre raonic au service quoi servent à
raonic bon voilà surnommée ming bon
ouais ouais tout à fait mature
je suis un peu abasourdi mature un
migros part si je remets je referme
tigres en s'offrant des partis comme ça
il a adressé non ça fait deux d'affilée
1 j'ai envie de dire quand il joue comme
ça dit tu comprends pourquoi il a battu
magnus à limerick style en plus non là
là franchement il a fait mal à la jambe
et game est donc à mettre les bonnes là
maintenant pour trouver que ces
tournants waits est un peu il s'est un
peu enflammés il était dans le turf eu
comme thème bien dire ouais t'as freddy
bongo qui on aurait dit un 2008 contre 1
2003 mais c'est un peu l'impression
qu'elle a laissé 1 l'an dernier la
partie de ding c'est à l'impression
qu'il veut contre un amateur quoi il
s'était déchiré brévonnes s'est pas
beaucoup mieux et prend pas henri iv
jamais aussi à [ __ ] de la france
alors du coup qu'est ce qu'on peut
écouter et reprendre les 3 alors fou
prend des cas tu prends de quoi du fou
se moque du pew ok prendre des trois etc
et ses quêtes
ça pue 1
cette dame à cette table des 22.3 ok bon
fin de la partie ça fait pas un et si je
prends du fou un taureau et damas est là
peut-être je vis au fonds cic gâte un
tas de demain à 8 du monde bat info
qu'un hongrois venger 6 2 ouais enfin je
semis en maintenant je sais pas tu en
prends ce qu'adam 8 nauroy schiste faut
toujours vérifier que peut-être m'amuser
dans le contrôle il va pas vouloir faire
un nul à lui par batterie kikla la
partie c'était pékin express
il ya aussi du f4 avec l'idée de me rend
fou g5
il est parti avec avec faut prendre b4
assez franchement c'est quand même le
couple torride ou entreprendre 23 août à
pau sur la dame ah non ça fait mal tu
sais dire que je serai dans une bande
dessinée mathieu ne pas je vais être
dans une bande dessinée c'est les gens
qui peuvent qui veulent mettre le lien
est ce que tu connais les fdp de
thibault n'y a pas du tout c'est une
bande dessinée qui est écrite par
apsalys que tu connais absolument pas ça
lui devant
du coup il écrit une bd où il ya des
youtuber qui ont des aventures et dans
le prochain épisode dans le deuxième
tome
j'y serai plus là seul nom j'ai dit les
fdp de tubes oignons du coup c'est les
gens qui veulent mettre le lien vers le
hull de la de la bd vous êtes les
bienvenus et donc j'aurai mon personnage
sur a peut-être une grotte dans le dans
la bd du coup c'est marrant haegeli la
connerie voilà j'ai besoin de toi ça tu
as trouvé sur internet les fdp de
thibaut n'ya non non je disais le jazz
l'ordinaire et 10 sur cc dit que c'est
que 0,20 que je pense que là il qu'on a
dit est correct en qualité de cadre d'un
mae 8 basse est en train de jouer ça
allait mais ça on est impressionnant
mathieu aujourd'hui on regarde sans ordi
et où on est on est partout c'est ici on
pensait qu'on était dans le dur mais il
ya peut-être un truc pour les membres ou
key c4 je pense dangereux damas lui 3ème
set
ben là je sais pas monsieur tanner un
regain fou qui vient sur ces 3 et
attaques de cette info comment ce marché
sa tête dameche monuc n'a pas été si
près si vous avez fait cai et ses quatre
en tout cas
bon après vous n'avez pas trouvé les
coûts de l'ordi quand ce n est à -2 et
il est à 2 - 1 - 0 2 oui on est relégué
les coups du champion du monde ça ça va
quoi on a trouvé les locaux appartement
on arriver peut-être qu'on a il a raté
les gains avant qu'on arrive on porte la
poste ce qu'il est en train de te dire
aurait on va me dire que tu la poisse et
et salua rba vaches qui attend j'ai
jamais compris son pseudo du coup air
bravache
mais on sait que j'ai compris ce qu'ils
ont une pause ici ça retombe ça
maintenant on va faire une pause je
pense ce match une fois que la partie de
manu sera fini comme tu veux on n'a pas
fait de pause jusque là on va en
profiter pour un peu souffler quoi
est-ce que la caricature de quelle
morale à moustache maximum qu'elle ait
craqué à moustache
moi j'ai vu que des esquisses j'ai pas
vu là enfin c'est pas que j'ai vu que ya
que des esquisses pour le mans n'y a pas
forcément le personnage final la
victoire est à quel point 4 points donc
il est à deux points de la victoire ce
soir il a dix points d'avancé y reste 12
points et enfin il ya deux points de vue
du match nul comme ce que s'ils s'y font
nulle en fait maxime qui gagne 4 018 sur
à égalité donc il a trois points de la
victoire et à 2,2 points de s'assurer au
moins le nul dean cain
voilà on est malin et le score à venir
une cale scène ses 9,3 pour magnus pour
le moment le pourcentage de gains de lvl
maintenant tu penses combien mathieu 2
3%
pas plus sain chez le monde qui gagne le
rapid déjà six games pas rapide c'est
quasiment non 6 pers est déjà finie et
si fait nul fort afin de gagner 4-0 buts
ça se fait après un ca se fait il reste
quand même point gaz une partie à quatre
points et quatre parties à deux points
donc il ya douze points à prendre
donc rapidement il sert à quoi déjà ce
tournoi vin c'est un tournoi qui sert
enfin trois prestigieux pour le prestige
le sénat peut-être le plus prestigieux
de l'année entre guillemets parce que
c'est sur plusieurs manches dans plein
de pays
et là c'est la demi finale finale et
avec beaucoup d'argent à minuit et ça se
passe à londres dans une jolie soldats
lui mais en plus ce serait dommage que
maxime elle j'ai fait 2e 2017 sur le
circuit deuxième en 2018 serait dommage
d'en refaire deuxième en 2019 parce que
c'est quand même une belle une belle
ligne ajoute à son palmarès ça va être
sera plus maxime vachier lagrave s'être
maxime poulidor lagrave quoi il sert et
internet c'est déjà très bien qui nous
gagne un petit peu quelque chose quand
même ce qui peut le faire donc
c'est le premier à quinze qui gagne
aussi fait nul c'est déjà gagné
et quand il ya 28 points en dessous de
sa williams 28 points en tout cas et non
non en fait il a raison c'est le premier
à quinze donc nulle en rapide tu as
raison il est juste éliminé en fait donc
en gros il faut qu'il peut faire nul
dans un blitz en fait il faut qu'ils
gagnent le rapide qui gagne 3 blood
c'est une aile pour la marque pionnière
jeu il fait nuit là que 14
maintenant ces deux points nul en rapide
en fait c'est un truc qui est pour ça qu
on s'est planté 9
un peu trop est ok a remis au moins il
réfléchit donc à homs en cas du contre
je sais pas si ça maintenant elle trouve
un avec mirella 15 with your daddy 10 à
vue d'année 6 points pour le clasico je
trouve pas ça normal sur deux jours
après peut-être que ça aurait mérité
quatre rapide 4 blitz mais bon pas
facile d'organiser peut-être en termes
de de temps pour penser qu' il ajoute on
pensait qu'après dame prend dame à
éviter quoi d'autre tu consolidé d'1 9 8
2 en 2008 3 6 on l'avait vu à temps et
si on était en h4 qui aurait peut-être
fou e7 est un grand malade
cécile puis à mascate après fawcett tu
commences à poser des questions à
peut-être fait rage 4 maintenant c'est
un peu longue
ne serait ce que pour prouver qu est
même peut-être point qu'après gd perpète
aa
on va voir ce qu'il a fait il a fait
d'armé trois pie vii avaient fui 3g 6
tours s'est il donc tu refuses tu
attends je vous prends ton temps du mal
français un nouveau procès dames 1 8
c'est le seul échec on est d'accord et
3,6 damme 6e j 5 d'un rêve steve mathieu
j'y suis damages sept ans qui l'a déjà
geda macheath g de macheist pour filmer
un peu à tâtons de petits moulins et
même coup d'avancé je suis pas du tout
l'idée que je nagerai pas vu mathieu il
a pris la dame muté chez ecc la partie à
roye h is no 6 hmm hmm la g6 je suis pas
sûr mais rouach un salaire de gagner
tout de suite pour moi non mais même si
cela aurait fait fi 3,5
mais la justice est là qui réfléchit
surréaliste et qui fait d'eux les deux
tours j'avoue quand il a envoyé 2 to et
voudront l'esprit à fond quand
maintenant il n'y a plus rien fait
fuiter jouer 3 5 dames 7 kg mesdames
juge adam g5 d'un match attends attends
tu entends c'est pas si simple
ils menacent d'un match 4 maths et break
3-1 chante bien qu'issue rungis où il
menace ça et là mais les blancs gueule
je pense là et sur d'apcher 5 à damas 7
et h3 et blanc gagne c'est un truc de
fou
ouais les plans qu'on a dit 'nous on
achète un poste de geci sillage au tempo
justice et rush 5 voire l'ordi 3,5 c -
10 ses filles donnent le set vas-y le
royaume
non mesdames cette dame du simple dames
g5 n'y a rien diatta pas de menaces
nb et provient d'un mot sida 9,7 g6pd
cesse c'est la variante qu'on a vu et si
là il n'a pas dû il a dû rater la dame
qui reviendra schiste comme moi et donc
regrets non et donc du coup il avait
prévu g6 bah ouais mais du coup franc et
fuit 3 5 des recettes seimat ses mains
il soude enfin genre c'est incroyable
j'ai jamais vu ça c'est joli comme ce
qu'il a vu comme un oignon du coup oui
face à reculer mais c'est joli
ben ouais magnus magnus c'est incroyable
quand même là c'est là c'est la gaffe
c'est la gaffe du mois là mathieu mais
il a joué beaucoup trop vite il avait
nagé en 4 secondes
combien 4 secondes 4 secondes bah il
relance le match
ah ok un peu de suspens après pas demain
il relance le match mais c'est vraiment
une gaffe en feng a fait maths en matant
3 c'est rare pour un champion du monde
et heureusement qu'il n'a pas perdu hier
le truc complètement foutu parce qu'il
serait mal dans le match ouais on le
sent je sens très clairement que la
défaite contre entre maxime l'a fait
sortir du tournoi
oui il a gagné celle d'après me sentais
que c'était déjà tort c'est bizarre mais
ça lui fait mal quand même et puis on
classement rapide
un béni coup les deux perdent tenzing se
rapproche de la première quand je vends
le live nadine il va plus que se
rapprochait surtout que les bonnes il
doit pas être très gras en rapide moi il
est 9e mondiale
ah non ils viennent de perdre du point
ce qui sait s écrie 2-0 contre 10
millions rapide il est pas si pas gras
c'est par française les 27 et enfin pour
moi c'est la démonte anna contre digne
qui a commencé à le faire douter à la
cera l'asim que fils il jouait déjà pas
très bien magnus un site au projet 3b il
faut que nous serons prendre deux offres
mais parce qu en fait ouais mais je
comprends en fait ce qu'il veut en
réalité ça même sans le pion peut quand
même ma t il abandonné à ses pieds
incroyable à l'herm a abandonné 7 paris
logis incroyable incroyable mathieu ça
c'est genre de choses c'est génial
du coup tu es tour c'est dans une demi
heure la prochaine écoutons va on va
laisser le chat nous confirme et puis si
c'est le cas je vais marcher parce ce
que je vois et créé au sinistre officiel
ouais donc je te propose je leur mets
quoi comme vidéo j'ai jamais eu à leur
base à 3 on my michel plus que ce 9 à 7
oui magnus et sert et maintenant même
mieux c'est serré donc ça c'est cool
donc ouais ouais c'est en restera bien
évidemment sur maxime parce qu'on 5 et
décisive en fait ouais surtout la
prochaine et puis après on verra si on
continue si on continue pas allez on se
mets tu sais quoi je mettais un truc un
peu un peu qui bouge vermette 1 je vais
mettre un replay d'un vieux speech s du
coup junior en bullet de malades
un truc qui leur fait mal cette écoute
je vais remettre ça ça leur fera des
vacances ça ça va aller ça allait m'être
bien attend juste de petites minutes
on revient à quelle heure du coup
on vient vers césar main je te propose
16h22 je serai là je vois mon petit tu
es tranquille
ouais moi ici celle qui est hélas -
hélas - juste une minute mathieu jeu
mais là je mets la pause et je te laisse
ebe qu'à son équipe à gagner mais il a
perdu aujourd'hui on arrête ça il était
bien et c'est le donne un pion en encre
ou le prendre en compte
il a coupé son enquête du genre mais une
petite pub aussi et on va lancer et
16h30 la prochaine partie way allez
c'est parti mathieu aller à tout de
suite les mecs vers 16 heures 22 donc
les amis on est on est on a le retour de
niall qui a plus qu'un point de retard
sur sam sevian samse vian supposé être
un petit peu moins fort en bullet mais
séduit 1 + 1 donc ça va être très chaud
forcément le l'américain qui débutait la
séquence de bullet avec deux points
d'avancé il ya plus qu'un point d'écart
ça va être tendu jusqu'au bout il doit
rester à peu près 27 minutes de jeu et
donc on est dans un nouveau système de
londres une nouvelle fois cette
structure de type français c'est une
partie qu'on a on a déjà vu cette
position dans le match et cavani qui
vient à eux trois les blancs qui veulent
fixer la case 5 chacun va neiger quatre
cavaliers eux cinq ils ont retardé le
rock pour pouvoir si jamais reprendre 2
h et mettre la pression sur le roc
adverse ou b 5 ans déjà parlé plus tôt
si on met la pression sur le cavalier
pour gagner cette case de saint cloud
qui arrivant au 5 mai ça va donner la
case f4 fatalement au cavalier noir mais
cette fois ci les blancs encore le fou
de cases blanches et donc y aura plus
les soucis qu'on a connu en début de
match avec le roi qu'il pouvait pas ok
cavaliers f5 est-ce que j'ai qu'après
jouable ici non il y aurait cavaliers
pros ou trois intermédiaires ce ne
serait pas une vraie fourchette
cavaliers pour j'imagine plutôt g prend
quoi que prend possible aussi mais après
rock à tour prendre encore plus
intéressant savait qu'après rock il faut
garder pour les noirs l'initiative
allait droit sinon ils se feront glisser
j'ai quatre tours prend aux cavaliers f4
donc il a filé la call of il a filé la
call of
et là peut-être petit rock tout bêtement
camp rock pardon tout bêtement
il n'y a pas de n'y a pas de mauvaises
et coups de me2 mauvais d'échec façon le
fou couvre et les noirs qui vont se
faire repousser petit à petit
éventuellement par du hk tour g1 h5 qui
peut faire mal à leurs espérances par
attention h4
5 tout ça n'est pas si simple il ya
aussi des quatre qui peut traîner il
fait tour d eux un touret fuite
est-ce que h4 scache 4 est une
possibilité peut-être f3 d'abord pour
consolider le pion et fermer la
diagonale du fou et peut-être maintenant
h4 intermédiaire le fou est attaquée
mais on n'a pas créé la dame qui est une
caisse éventuellement évidemment plus
forte que le fou la dame va probablement
repartir vers sète le fou vers détroit
c'est pas grave je serais échangé le fou
ici on a un avantage matériel et ce
cavalier h4 est un vrai monstre baies 5
pouces et deux peut-être dû h5 g5 ou g5
direct les noirs en tout cas qu'ils
s'organisent qui attaquent à fond
allèles dames la tour en 3 la tour en
des 8 du coût actuellement le pion e5 le
cavaliere 4 pardon n'est plus en prise
la tour qu'il y en ait en des huit pour
jouer des quatre tours eu un peut-être
des quatre qui va arriver dame prend h4
le pion h qui tombe c'est vrai que j'ai
pas trop aimé pour les blancs ce plan-là
de partir sur la colonne je vois pas
trop ce qu'on fait niall sarine qui a
perdu le fil de la partie le fils il va
falloir le retrouver parce que lui
samuel sevian le fil
il a peut-être d'un match de tours h1
des coups simples dames e3 qui attaque
peut-être tout rachat d'amd de il
revient damage de tours h1 et peut-être
pas une idée ce cavalier f4 est vraiment
monstrueux la dame qui parent bessette
c'est plutôt le roi blanc qui se fait
attaquer ça le sévillan qui est vraiment
vraiment chaud mais il donne la casse
des quatre à présent peut-être faut-il
rentrer dans la finale qui on prend
peut-être four b3 dam des quatre îles
joutes damas est trop il joue pour tours
à huit dames à un match c'est le beau
jeu c'est le beau jeu et surtout b 3
pions c4 puis on prend ces cinq tours à
huit qui va arriver foulée trois des
quatre en premier alors attention il
veut quoi il veut du fou prend f3 et
fougueux 4 pour complètement enlevé au
ces jolies le fou qui revient au g4 qui
va venir au f5 et qui va complètement
bloqué le roi dans le corner fouet f5
échec et tour à 8 me paraît fort mais il
a commencé par g5 pour une raison qui
m'échappe le roi blanc qui va pouvoir
partir vers ces deux dames à 5 attention
ces six monneret plomb c'est qu'ils
parlent fou échec roi c1 dames un roi
des deux était à matam b de roi ou trois
cavaliers g2 je ne sais pas sa part de
partout autour des 8 il prend le roi
contre pied
il prend la tournure
en des 8es yade à main maths qui menace
est ce que yahoo prend aussi ses chèques
peut-être non y avait été défendue du
coup il a rendu la dame la dame qui va
pouvoir revenir vers à 5 éventuellement
aux cavaliers de m'attendre victoire de
sa viande qui reprend deux points
d'écart e45 du coup de nouveau les
blancs on va jeter un oeil sur le
chronomètre il reste encore 22 minutes
de jeu au f5 je crois bien que c'est le
gambit janish le gambit janish qui est
envoyé par nial sarine yal sarine qui a
de nouveau deux points de retard mais
qui n'a vraiment pas bien maîtrisé la
partie précédente ils avaient l'avantagé
il a perdu le fil cavaliers pro 5 petit
roquet c3a les savants chez nous on va
mettre une d'amande que en d6 le fou qui
va peut-être venir angers 4 niall qui
doit absolument recoller au score sous
peine d'avoir un retard beaucoup trop
grand fou p 6
on va voir est ce qui va prendre le fou
en b 6 il a le temps le fou de toute
façon sous pression lecavalier a eu cinq
menace est tout de même en y prend puis
on prend qu'elle prend celle ci prend
les pions il ya depuis leucate qui va
tomber ce qu'il va y avoir de la tacc
pour les noirs je n'ai pas l'impression
les blancs qui pourront blindes
éventuellement par f3 le fou qui sera
éteint damev 3 proposait change des
dames est ce qu'on peut aller prendre en
d4 et jouait sur un truc complètement
fou avec du cavaly g4 non il le fait pas
il échange les dames mais si on compte
les pions c'est à la fin du village
qu'on compte les maisons les amis et la
fin du village le village blanc une
maison de maisons trois maisons quatre
maisons cinq maisons six maisons côté
noir on n'a que cinq maisons il ya une
maison de retard est ce que les noirs
vont pouvoir reconstruire des maisons
voire même avoir un permis de
destruction sur les maison blanche
c'est à voir est ce que la mairie
donnera les autorisations c'est une
question en cours pour le moment côté
indien donc ni al sarine qui peut quand
même compter sur les fous de couleurs
opposées pour résister le pion à 3 peut
être un petit peu sous pression
attention tour d un pour chasser le fou
et éventuellement des découvertes
si le cavaliere venaient à bouger il y
aurait du pousser deux c'est pour ça
qu'ils jouent ces 5 mai fouet f4
intermédiaire tout reprend des trois
pions prend des 4 enfin pions prend des
quatre tours prend des 3 puis on prend
ces trois tons pensée 3 et option des
six resterait en difficulté ligne al
sarine qui semble en difficulté
effectivement mais il a un peu plus de
temps cependant la position est assez
simple à jouer ici mais il rajoute du
bordel au bordel cavaliers des cinq
surtout reprend detroit il veut faire
qu'il est pro f 4 mai fu prend des six
est la question
il prend maintenant une fois et il va
prendre du cavalier avec l'idée que
surtout on prend des quatre cavaliers eu
deux échecs la petite pointe du joueur
indien qui essayent de s'en sortir
élégamment mayroy f1 on empêche tous les
problèmes et maintenant ton pions des 4
et toujours en prise à mon avis le
joueur américain ici a un avantage
certain
cav a lieu quatre tours prend des quatre
il n'y a pas de piège le gambit janish a
pas fonctionné mais il va essayer de
jouer tour ces deux pour s'activer à
fond sur la deuxième rangée le joueur
blanc qui réussit à remettre son fou en
2 1 pour défendre le plan f2 et colmater
la seconde rangée mais pour le moment ça
tient tout est protégé le pion à troyes
le pion f2 à cavaliers pros f2 à le à
denis brogniart qui a été lâchée et du
coup la tour qui arrive en f2 mais les
blancs qui colmate par tour g4 encore et
qu'ils vont réussir à se consolider
alors maintenant est ce qu'on va voir un
g6 côté noir ou h6 pour jouer g5
éventuellement pour ces deux rois h7
mais les blancs qui vont jouer pour
tourner un tour 17 peut-être tour à tour
g3 qui défend le pion et les blancs qui
vont réussir à s'activer la tour en g3
c'est une pièce ses positions vraiment
préférentiels pour cette tour pourquoi
parce qu'elle défend g2 et l attaque g7
donc elle fait de boulot c'est du deux
en un c'est le shampoing 3 en 1 presse
et maintenant on va être obligé avec les
noirs de défendre une finale avec une
tour une tour un pion de moins et elle
est dure à jouer c'est du bullet et
c'est pas une balle de match bien
évidemment mais c'est une vraie balle de
break ont mènerait on pourrait dire de
7,0 côté côté sévillan qui montrent le
roi après avec le pion la tour derrière
ça peut faire nul mais il va falloir
faire un numéro d'équilibriste côté
indien pour la tenir ses biens en plus
qui a déjà montré à plusieurs reprises
qu'il était vraiment bon enfant avec peu
de temps sur la pendule le roi là qui
m'ont tant j'ai cinq tours b3 qui va
être forcé mais à tout reproche et 6 à
trois points à 5 tours angers 63.5 et ça
va faire plus trois pour le joueur
américain je vous l'annonçais c'est
complètement gagnant c'est assez simple
à gagner après c'est normal de côté
niall sarine de la joue encore un peu
mais non on vous
la déception nada sur son visage une
petite grimace qui a été lâché et ça
continue qu'à l'épreuve de était jolie
mais le joueur américain qui a très vite
réagi en mettant la tour sur la colonne
g et c'est ça qui a fait la différence
maintenant on a un genre de système
stonewall avec les blancs avec le fou
qui a réussi à passer angers 5 en
premier c'est hyper hyper hyper
important là pour l'indien de marquer il
ya plus le choix maintenant il n'y a
plus le choix alors est-ce qu'on peut un
cavalier e 5 essayer de mettre une dame
en âge 5
pas si sûr la f6 peut-être on laisse le
fou en prison on attaque à fond f si
j'imagine du damage 5 à la barbare à la
dure allez y prend on peut reprendre
même de f issifou pranger 5e pranger
cinq dames pranger 5 on aurait fou prend
h cet échec méprendre 2d aussi
intéressant pour bien amener les pions à
l'est le roi et mener la traque niall
sarine qui réfléchit il a un petit peu
changé de braquet il jouait très vite
dans les parties précédentes mais
maintenant il prend le temps de jouer et
on a des prend 1,5 donc il veut vraiment
vraiment vraiment amener tous les pions
vers l'est le roi f5 y ait joué souvent
dangereux position en tout comme g4
intéressant pour venir s'en prendre à ce
pion f5 puis reprise en passant est
aussi intéressante
après le petit défaut ses compères la
mainmise qu'on avait sur la case m6 met
cependant le cavalier va revenir vers la
case eux cinq ils y arrivent d'ailleurs
justement food et 6 pour le chasser et
les blancs qui me paraissent un petit
peu dans le dur
un petit peu dans le dur parce que le la
case des 5
il n'est pas peut être pas possible de
la de la conserver et maintenant les
noirs qui peuvent installer leurs
cavaliers sur quatre est complètement
coupée cette attaque blanche
je dirais inial sarine qui veut jouer le
tout pour le tout mais qui va peut-être
pas au bout de ses convictions et
maintenant le fou est enfermé alors
est-ce que c'est grave non parce que
damages 5 et sur pied on prend on pourra
jouer fou j'ai six ou plus on prend et à
les mater à la dure des cas être
maintenant et il faut y aller faut aller
jusqu'au bout de tes convictions résiste
prouve que tu existes peut-être fou
prend h 6 puis on prend et roy g1 et
tant pis tu envoies à aimer sur fion
prend il y aura pu comprendre la dame
intervient défense non je dis n'importe
quoi
donc j'ai 3 eyes fait des trois assez
bien joué des trois assez bien bien joué
il coupe complètement les ailes des
blancs et là il va y avoir du pion
pranger 5 puis on prend et foin f4 au ca
fait mal
trois jets d'oeufs et fou prend g5
élimine le pion g6 qui pouvait fermer la
porte
et alors là maintenant attaque moi si tu
peux alors là encore une petite petite
combine sur damev cette tour prend 1,6
il va falloir vérifier qu'on se fasse
pas maté côté blanc dans tous les cas la
finale serait très bien pour les noirs
attention tout de même ce evian qui
prend le temps voilà c'est ce qu'il a vu
mais il va faire juste à me ranger ici
s'il va rentrer dans la finale je vous
parlais de cette finale il ya juste
quelques secondes et cette finale elle
est complètement gagnante nihal sarine
qui n'y peut rien le pion détroit est
vraiment fort tour f1 très bien joué on
échange ta tour pas si mon pouce des dos
d un sévillan qui s'envolent +4 à la
surprise générale c'est le joueur
américain
tel un boa constrictor qui aura
construit qui aura tueur a construit ce
match depuis les cinq plus un ce match
en cinq sets
et petit à petit l'étreinte qui ce qui
s'enroule autour du cou de l'indien un
coût qui du coup est complètement con
qu'on construisait par par le bo
américain le bois américain qu'il a dans
système de londres a pas du tout réussi
à mettre la pression
il va à jouer à une position plus ou
moins égales mais il reste plus que 15
minutes de jeu est-ce que ça le gêne de
faire une nulle en trois minutes ici non
ce serait une bonne opération pour le
joueur américain qui forcerait à
l'amiable sarine à faire la différence
avec les blancs mais malheureusement il
aura pas quatre parties avec les blancs
donc il faut absolument marquer côté
noire fournie à la sarine alors ils
échangent tout ça ait changé stratégie
intéressante c'est vianne vraiment qui
est aujourd'hui vraiment très lucide il
connaît le score il comprend la
dynamique du match il doit regarder les
speechs s est hissée qu'une nul dans ce
à ce moment du match est en sa faveur il
joue le système de londres il laisse la
variante avec des 5
il va là yves il fait il fait le truc
qu'il faut et maintenant ils en
profitent et il va pouvoir laisser
tourner la pendule
on pourra pas dire que ce n'est pas
fair-play parce que cette position là
elle se joue c'est pas une position où
on dit il faut faire nul obligatoirement
c'est une position qu'on peut jouer et
il va laisser tourner le chrono c'est
bien joué c'est bien joué
stratégiquement il faut féliciter le
joueur américain pour un choix
pragmatique intéressant plein de bon
sens il à peine 18 ans mais il est déjà
plein d'expériences et de bons choix
attention tout de même de pas se prendre
un pion passé à et crée le pion pas
cessé c'est bien joué
il se crée le pion pas cessé il est ce
pas ce petit avantage du pion pas
s'éloigner et donc le joueur américain
qui a qui peut plus jouer les finales de
deux pions puisque le pion à 5 et pas
s'éloigner alors est ce qu'il va pouvoir
jouer avec ses 5 c'est bien joué là ce
que fait ni al sarine
c'est bien joué mais en fait ça fait pas
grand chose parce que ces quatre baies 5
est à peu près équivalent à 7 à 7 v6
donc la position est juste complètement
nul est ce que le joueur américain va
faire nul ou est-ce qui va jouer la
montre ça va être un petit peu la
question de cette fin de partie
proposition 2 nuls
de la part de niall sarine refusé parce
evian alors est ce qui va basculer du
côté sombre de la force du côté gris
tchouk où tu joues pendant des plombes
pour faire la pendule simplement pour
faire tourner la pendule ou est ce que
maintenant que la position est vraiment
égalé qui a plus de chances de gain pour
les deux il va rester quelque part faire
j'ai envie de dire le statu quo non on
va pas dire le le statu quo mais je veux
dire juste juste faire là nul au moment
opportun
ou est-ce qu'il va jouer jusqu'au bout
moi je le vois bien continuer il est
parti là dedans alors on n'aime pas trop
ça ici bien évidemment mais c'est le jeu
qu'est ce que vous voulez signal sarine
voulait éviter ça il avait qu'à voir
quatre points d'avance là les quatre
points d'avance son côté américain et
l'américain qui utilisent les règles en
sa faveur
est-ce qu'on peut le critiquer pour ça
je ne crois pas les amis je ne crois pas
alors le roi g6 dame c63 g7 et c'est
comme ça et fessé 5 alors il donne
l'illusion de jouer pour gagner mais en
réalité c'est complètement nul
mais il ira y réussit à faire tourner il
fait tourner la pendule fait tourner
tourner tourner tourner et maintenant le
joueur a bien qui va qui peut qui n'y
peut rien qui n'y peut rien ce prévenu
puissant au bout la thèse c'est le
problème qui fait d'être en retard dans
le match alors c'est pas si clair à mon
avis encore dans le sens où le joueur
indien réussi à se créer des chances ou
pas il y aura toujours un père pète de
toute façon mais c'est lyon qui joue
quand même le jeu un cerf qui fait nul
salle mais pas trop sale non plus certes
y'a du contre jeu ça joue la partie
continue le pion bva avancer donc là ce
qui fait c'est qu'il veut envoyer un
pion mais le truc c'est que
c'est plutôt les blancs au final la dame
des cinq damage 5 des 4ème et il va y
avoir mangé combien de minutes avec ça
il va avoir mangé presque 5 minutes et
c'est même pas sûr qu'ils la gagnent pas
il va prendre la nulle maintenant ou pas
et même pas aimé la pression maintenant
il est même mieux
ouais c'est bien joué assez bien joué et
la dame g3 contre échec et il va gagner
parce que et chaque échec échange de
dames et ça gagne avec le pion j'ai
assez roublard de la part de ces vian
qu'elle roublard échange des dames et
saga inial sarine écoeuré écoeuré salle
sévillan là qui a fait un job incroyable
avec cette partie il a laissé tourner
quatre minutes trente de pendule et il a
quand même marqué le point et c'est la
partie qui décide du match les amis ils
gagnent là dessus mais vraiment plein
d'expérience peut-on critiquer sevian
pour avoir joué comme ça honnêtement je
ne le pense pas parce que si vous
commencez à critiquer c'est bien pour
jouer comme ça vous ne regardez plus une
compétition vous ne regardez plus une
compétition c'est à dire que c'est comme
au foot vous mener 1-0 et vous regardez
plus parce que les mecs tiennent leur
but
au rugby vous menez de 2,8 points ou 2 5
points à la fin du match et vous faites
des petits pick and go vous garder le
ballon et vous faites du cache ballon à
la monster du coup on regarde plus rien
sevian qu'il a joué à l'expérience et
qui s'est même payé le luxe de la sphère
pas trop sale c'est à dire qu'il a quand
même gagné la partie dont qui peut ce
qui peut s'asseoir à la table de ses
vian et lui dire tu as pas été fair play
non il a joué la règle à fond et il n'a
pas dépassé il n'a pas fait la grille
tchouk il n'a pas dépassé les limites du
fair play du correct il est resté à la
limite il a fait les choses comme il
fallait
comme un grand et ça vraiment les amis
c'est à souligner on peut pas critiquer
un joueur pour faire ça au contraire je
pense qu'il faut le féliciter pour sa il
utilise son avantage il utilise c'est
lui qui a pris les quatre points
d'avance c'est normal qu'il ait le
crédit pour ça il a forcé son adversaire
à forcer le gain il a obligé sarine a
joué le gard à fond il était là en
compte
il a contré il a fini proprement c'est
vraiment du travail d'orfèvre ce qu'a
fait c'est bien c'est à ce moment là du
match est vraiment très solide vraiment
bien joué voilà je suis content d'avoir
d'avoir vécu ce moment là parce qu'on a
vu on a vu un beau match le match n'est
pas fini mais mathématiquement c'est que
c'est fini on a vu un beau match et on a
vu vraiment une réalisation mieux que
chez les adultes quelque part et ouais
c'est comme quand tu as un gros stack au
poker avant la bulle que tu mets la
pression c'est c'est normal d'avoir
c'est comme au tour de france quand tu
as deux minutes d'avancé que le maillot
jaune ils attaquent pas et qui reste
dans le peloton et que ya le peloton des
favoris et qu'à plus de guimaëc et qu'en
fait ils te tiennent ils te font la
technique de la sky et que et qu'ils
attaquent janet même s'ils sont plus
forts ils te laissent épuisé et il te
rases aux poteaux c'est tout avec à être
devant donc ce qu'il a fait c'est tout à
fait correct est donc maintenant il
reste le combier la ja il n'y avait pas
d'âme ananda main ça marchait pas
évident à mes fins toujours est donc
maintenant il reste combien il reste 7
minutes 52 matchs ben il y aura lieu
rail aura pas à y aura rien les mecs
parce que la même mais même s'ils
gagnent de toute façon il ya encore
vingt secondes de pendule à tourner donc
au moins il va encore jouer une
trentaine de coups et il faut au moins
encore une minute mais alors au super
bas mot pour gagner ça et en plus c'est
les noirs qui sont gagnants parce qu'ils
ont un peu un pion de plus pas gagnant
non non les noirs sont pas du tout
gagnant c'est les noirs
bon alors ils sont pas mieux en fait
mais on va dire que les blancs sont pas
bien ne font pas mieux du tout je vois
pas pourquoi les blancs devraient être
mieux ici un malgré l'activité il ya
quand même ce pion à reprendre et dans
tous les cas mais même si la gagne il va
falloir du temps - hyprescon c'est plus
agréable à jouer pour les blancs mais
mais bon c'est très très dur et très
long a gagné quand bien même il y
arriverait en plus la même mentalement
c'est compliqué la tour qui revient en
d1 il va réussir à faire tour un prénom
ça va tout à fait pour les noirs et est
en plus soit comme je disais la ville
est sonné la pendule hires quoi il reste
6 minutes 50 ya pas de maths il va
récupérer de pionsat va s'échanger et là
je dirais que mathématiquement il est la
victoire est déjà assurée à 99,99 pour
cent je donnerai une cote de 10 mille
contre 1 pour fournir le sarine je
prendrai quand même c'est bien messi
gagne cette partie là ou s'il fait nul
il y aura même plus de côtes ce sera ce
sera du zéro contre un ce sera fini ce
sera cote aaa serait une cote à
d'ailleurs sarine qui comprend sur la
caméra qu le match est perdu il reste il
reste six minutes 20 l an de toute façon
la plus simple c'est absolument
impossible
dans tous les cas ce sera une victoire
et la fausse info pranger 3ème un match
on est de retour
on est nous retourner on y croit bah
écoute ça part de là bref c'est la
prochaine c'est maintenant ou jamais
écoute si la gagne il reste en vie et
envie de tout est possible donc
ne partez pas envie de dire vous revenez
en plus c'est le toujours le rush
donc s'il gagne ce live lundi ce sont 1
touche a donc il faut le faire douter
il a des raisons de se sentir à ton chat
blanc d'ailleurs vu ce qu'il fait ou
alors il faut le toucher physiquement
ouais il faut le faire douter parce que
c'est là quand tu es dans les sons il
est dans sa zone de confort là depuis le
début
ouais bah oui il fait un gros match par
thil mam en oublier la première où il
font nul
une grosse partie encore la première en
fait si s'il fait pas l'erreur à la fin
il aurait pu lui mettre juste 3 0 en
jouant parfaitement quoi la saxe et que
tu te prendre 2 0 est longue c'est
quasiment fini en fait le marché
ouais ce qui est normal aussi petit
public si rappelez vous du match se
vident leurs cars yakine en finale de
coupe du monde j'imagine
c'était enfin il est incroyable ce match
et c'est finalement cet écart yakine qui
l'avait emporté au bout du bout du bout
quoi elle s'est juste en aide l'autre
faisait tout pour pas gagné chars et les
hacher fait l'été un coût du seul de
l'acadie il joue autre chose gibbs
mais bon c'est la tension mais celui-là
rossi avait fait un gros paquet de
gaffes non dans le match de mercredi la
cave et à huy ah oui c'est une heure qui
a gaffé c'est karim qui ramassent est
vrai mais ils ont libéralisé c'est fini
pour clarifier et non ils gagnent
scritta parties doivent gagner quand
même il ya une odeur une partie je crois
il a plus de plus de 50 fils une tour en
deux ou en a un truc comme ça qu'est ce
qu'il voit de la soupe âge mais je finis
mon thé matcha tranquille à la tienne
ouais enfin frère de thé quoi il ya de
la vodka dans people bien je fais du
malade tu enlèves l'a dit je commence
vraiment à jeun genre ma mère m'a
demandé elle m'a dit mais no fake il a
agen le yen au fait qu'il est vraiment
agents à quantico montrent autant mieux
non mais tu vois des fois elle me dit tu
vas même être qu'il le connaît bien et
si tu t'étais pas sur quoi vit dans
juste il est tellement heureux
en fait que du coup du coup ça donne
cette impression quoi parce qu'il est
très heureux
oli qui fait il aime bien être en france
et même bien a commenté avec toi
hellemmes les échecs aussi cannes ouais
est ce que tu aimes bien dino fait ouais
ma mère elle dit no fake ma mère l'autre
jour elle m'a même dit sous le nom ma
mère elle suffit elle suit le délire
donc elle peut être pu elle peut dire
nos fait qu'elle peut dire hills ou quoi
marrant mais bon allez allez allez
jeunes encore dans la tête quoi et pas
que j'aie nantes ou non le oui/non m'a
rempli tout temps très heureux de
commenter et très heureux de tout mais
c'est vrai qu'il aime beaucoup les
échecs comme tu le dis et donc plus
jouer aussi d'avis que c'est une drogue
en fait cela on en discutait est
différent si on a discuté dans au dîner
avec rihanna et d'expliquer à ma femme
qui joue pas du tout aux échecs que
s'ils jouent une partie s'est finie en
fait il va reprendre
ouais dit c'est très dangereux c'est
très dangereux
non il est pas fini il a trois points
mais dans tous les cas les jeux jusqu'au
bout un ca oui mais nous je pense pas
qu'on après à moins que tout le monde
veuille suivre magnus aronian pourquoi
pas on peut mais je pense pas qu'on
fasse les parties de maxime une fois que
c'est fini quoi je pense d'ailleurs
qu'on devrait pas jouer enfin
honnêtement je vois pas vraiment le nom
au jeu quoi les partis de voir le match
est fini
1 est ce que ça va compter pour le
classement sarkozy pour le pressent de
shorts sorte qu'il avait fait une
réclamation dont il joue un match oui
fans jusqu'à il avait gagné le match
mais hyper la dernière il avait demandé
que la partie soit pas comptabilisé
parce que quand le match est déjà gagné
ok ça il avait il a obtenu gain de cause
ouais non non parce que dans le
règlement c'était écrit ça mais dans la
base en fait il a raison je sais pas ça
aille la raison non mais pour moi tu
vois c'est un petit peu précises et en
fait le match doit s'arrêter quand c'est
fini
et si tu la joues ajuste ses produits
ben seulement web mais en fait enfin
c'est marrant ah oui donc du coup
peut-être ça compte pas pour les jours
tu vois je pensais que ça compte
automatiquement non mais tu vois dans
mon esprit c'est un petit peu comme tu
fais roland garros et a gagné 3,7 et
puis on fait quand même joué sept
numéros 4 et 5 quoi tu fais un peu la
gueule quand même après la comme c'est
un show sur une scène et où tu payes ton
ticket pour tenir un gars aussi mais il
force les joueurs à jouer
ouais ouais bah prénom tous les dents
tous les trucs comme ça normalement
quand le match est fini par me marc en
coupe davis il faut jouer les matches
qu'ils jouent pour rien mais après c'est
les matches après la garde à un speech
est remis à dos un agent peu plus
enfants speech s non mais c'est
n'importe quoi dans le cahier des
matières et c'est génial mais quand il
ya de ça c'est juste ça injuste si je
suis le courageux qui a commenté quand
même nepomniachi danielian tu vois
et combien 14 ans non je crois que ça
finit par un si gros score peut-être 24
à 5 ou quelque chose comme ça mais ménéz
paul où il apprit genre 12 13 points
d'avancé puis après il a un peu il a
soufflé quoi tu me donnes
mais il y en a d'autres genres un haka
il aurait essayé de faire il aurait
essayé de faire fanny quoi le
connaissant il y en a qui lie et d'alain
final 2 à 2 est assez ludique 24,2
peut-être que j'avais vu plus haut face
à est paru gros en fait le sort qu'elle
a fait donc peut-être deux points au vu
du match qu'il avait étonné tu vois la
terre la bande tort moi j'avais peur de
me prendre un truc comme ça j'ai vu à
nice sont près de 8 090 non mais c'est
un peu l'humiliation et non un mot
souffrance allen toi tu as pris combien
j'ai fait 5e minute à perdre à fait
discutable mais tu domines et dans les
parties en soit je deviens minier mais
je tombais donc cette belle jambe je
commence avec 0 sur 2 après je reviens
après jir dont je gagne une partie par
connexion
ouais ça j'ai vu ça bon j'étais mieux
mais bon je suis obligé de la guinée
mais moi il était plus fort que moi mais
je trouve que je joue mieux crime mais
très souvent j'avais emprunté gestique
souvent domine mais ne gagnent pas
toujours en projet chez sigma fin ça
dépend si maxime joue
ce qui est pas sûr sûr avec les
candidats ou quoi je sais pas combien de
matches il va jouer mais si maxime joue
beaucoup de matchs on a une belle équipe
un il ya plus de moyenne de lots ya plus
de la plus de moyenne de lots l'équipe
type en gros je peux te la dire que je
peux le dire à tout le monde a encore
l'équipe type si tout le monde peut
jouer
c'est maxime morin baccio de maxxo 3 don
d'irriter les trois premiers lots
français et gozzo aux quatre pas mal et
godin et gozzo à 4 je voulais pas
prendre goût à mon psy aussi mais en
remplaçant je pense sur internet gozzo
plus fort très fort mathieu pas si clair
la nana l'apôtre moi même après naïm et
oui la nuit la dernière après ouais moi
l'appel de la gauche peut jouer à la
place des trois autres c'est plus dur
pour moi
non après le truc c'est que à mon avis
il y aura quasi jamais cette équipe les
rats parce que maxime et baky ça
m'étonnerait qu'ils jouent beaucoup de
matchs donc l'équipe ça a plus souvent
ressemblé à la gare de götze au toit et
un mage aussi jouent avec nous autres
quoi ça plutôt être ça l'équipe en
réalité lanta ce qu'il veut faire une
interaction avec le pass coup ils s'en
mordront française à fin mars à savalou
alberta ces français et non oui oui oui
c'est pour ça que j que c'est ok et oui
je viendrai commenté de temps en temps
si je joue pas j'espère bien j'espère
bien un mur tasser le plus français des
casaques avec vlad
mais j'ai relu canton avait commenté
l'approché smic c'est marrant en plus de
cette époque qui joue c'est ton équipe
tu es complètement raté complètement
aspiré dans le truc genre non c'est pas
mal non mais un mur tu as mur tu as toi
et non il jouera et il ya peut-être
après je sais pas s'il pourra jouer deux
bases avaient sami aussi ça michaud
caire qui voulaient nous rejoindre mais
elle à sa fin avec les trucs de moyenne
à 2005 et où il était bien mais là ça va
être un peu dur mais après
il peut être peut être pas mal mais si
ça me suis pas si aujourd'hui on est
dans un bon jour
après c'est sûr que ce soit pour moi
pour cette joie ou quoi ça va être plus
difficile de jouer quoi dans ces
conditions-là l'assiette pas de moyenne
et noël moi je peux venir faire une robe
quoi s'il faut mais nous attendrons
placements non pas le remplacement dans
ma préparation comment se passe la
saison
ce que je pense faire c'est que battant
qu'on vous quelque chose les plus forts
joue et puis après tu vois comme chez
cette joie il aime bien jouer moi aussi
ou quoi peut-être une fois qu'on est ce
qu a pas de relégation il ya plus de
relégation en fait d'accord donc si à un
moment donné après il ya cette journée
de championnat assez après cinq journées
de championnat on peut plus monter on
fera peut-être jouer une équipe pour
faire plaisir quoi ceux qui veulent
jouer j'aurai pas forcément demandé à
maxime lagarde machin de se fatiguer ou
mvl ou quoi se fatiguer une fois qu'on
est si on est éliminé mais bon tout est
bidon et du coude ou deux jours à son
copain ce jour avec la pologne
voilà vous avez bien j'allais me demande
de tout il va jouer avec la pologne et
ils ont une grosse équipe parce qu'ils
auront tout d'abord juste à sec et à
peut-être mis ton et je sais plus qui
quoi bon après il a dit me tombent pas
très fort oui j'ai pas de raison qu'ils
sont pas mauvais mais sa jument ça y est
c'est reparti au nom de quel scénario
paraîtra maxime d'égaliser bas tout
simplement de gagner quoi je suis amer
c'est bon mais sûrement bord
macha mieux 4 ouais ok elle pense ça je
connais bien moi ces cinq jeunes turcs
on sait que ces forêts sont pour jouer
un pion de zolder pour josé cat est sûr
et je voulais plus est parti de
référence des parties de loyer je crois
que j'ai vu a pas longtemps une vieille
partie debout de vigny koussa s'est pas
fait ou les jeu excessif justement avec
les noirs et ou bobigny qu'avec
complètement dominé avec les blancs
cassés 6,6 menace des cadets jouent
cette position en partie non guerrier
pas longtemps prises des 5 g/jour de
fort prix des 5 e des fourbes et 5 en un
an
en e2 pas si belle d'ailleurs mais il ya
des cas d'un cloud et si c'est le bon
coup est en fait pourquoi je pense que
c'est une bonne pour les
noir parce que sur des 4 puis on prend
qu'avaient les prends petit rock est
jouable
on n'est pas obligé de pas maintenant un
trou 17 parce que sur quelques français
6 bat b prend et tourbe éviter il vous
prend h2o fou g4 l'a d'ailleurs c'est
peut-être fou j'ai cathy c'est le plus
facile et tour ses vitres il ya beaucoup
de jeu quoi un tac tac pas le pion je
vais te montrer une partie que j'ai
joués vézina la pause ok processes and
ont pris cette salle rock rock et là le
coup de wailly c'est fou ces sept et
j'ai joué c'est en partie la faute 2
ardemment plus d'âme des 6 g iii et là
coup fantastique the way to b 6
maintenant que le x fait son job on tape
sur des caps
il y des fous à 3 et excuse de te le
dire mais c'est un peu le ce qu'on a
appris avec la série de vidéos avec la
dent et que je connaissais certains
trucs c'était une communauté d'agglo
5,95 à il envoie la kalach mais j'y joue
sans parti dont souffrent les fuites
propres et grosses compensation j'ai
gagné une bonne partie la dernière ronde
de l'open de londres ligne
les américains avec les noirs laqués
noir je gagne ces deux gars qui est
processus il ya découle pays les deux
aussi potes mais donc ouais donc je
contrôle je pensais que ça n'était pas
mal admet d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'il a je
faisais ce qu il a fait cet écart a lié
des deux ouais donc qui les deux c'est
pas le plus joué d'un nom pour moi dame
de 6,7
on m'avait dit en f3 et deux strophes
logique à quatre couches provence quoi
j'ai 3 tu sais pas je réfléchis je
croyais qu'à et des cats je pense mais à
merpins cafu attend on va voir on va
voir s'il ya des coups il a fait
maintenant il n'a pas joué kf3 si jouer
ouais ben ça oblige fou g4 c'est sûr
mais j'aime pas d'emma fin j'aime pas
des masses et blanc ça c'est un des
trucs qu'on n'a pas fait tu as dans les
si on refaisait un deuxième volume c'est
jouer avec le pion isolé pour la nul
aussi
mais fougerais 4 donc on a joué trois
qua non j'ai trouvé refuge et 4g dont 6
ch et trois sur qui est des cas tu mets
peut-être vous défouler 6 maintenant je
suis content je suis censé connaître
cabinet de me semblait qu'il prendrait
quatre d'abord un ski et pourquoi sera
un sens de présenter quatre c'est de
comprendre regardez le châtaignier ce
que dingjian à regarder les vidéos sur
le pion isolé bah écoute on a
l'impression mais c'est que ça doit
l'être en veulent et ils veulent et les
traduire en chinois d'ailleurs baisse le
niveau marketing c'est loin d'être ou
wayne ont ils dit que chinois c'est un
très gros marché que et qu'il ya
personne qui fait du contenu fuji
inquiète
qu'est-ce qui peut jouer c'est dur de
trouver autre chose que j'ai trop nous
vous pensez si c'est un peu comme si ces
concessions et puis on prend et 3 500
n'en est peut-être tu fais fou 17 même
temps qu'un juif ou 17 c ou même fou ces
8es joue pour ses seins à l'air fou
auquel je protège ça je vous pour
pousser 6 au prochain
[Musique]
fu g4g 3 c'est flou c'est n'importe quoi
genre liquide est fou prend ses six
parce que j'ai trois qui les prend des
cas qui a peut-être juste un problème
concret ok dams et de hockey weeks je
comprends ce qu'il veut faire et du coup
il te dit que sur ces 5 et laqué et b5
night tu me prends la paire de fois ici
diouf ou 17 cabines f5
bon bref trois cas les premières trop
aux puces attend ça a coupé quant à
parler je disais que si vous prenez 3 on
peut jouer pour le petit plus ce
qu'avaient les prend et moi on joue on
joue contre les pions pendant quoi tour
c'est un tour de 1
un petit coup de g3 qui avait h 4 non
c'est clairement un petit plus donc
peut-être que fuji cat est pas le seul
coup tu as tu peux prendre des codes
mais maintenant si je prends la catch
prendre la dame amis c'est pour ça que
moi je pense qu'il fallait je comprend
des quatre avants revient pas ici et les
deux qui prendrait quatre ans des quatre
dames des six indécence f3 et rouge et
quatre non ouais bah si ça va dont 6,6 à
une logique ouais faut au 5è dan prend
1,5
il y a un problème il ya donc du coup
qu'est ce tu fais ouais c'était sa peau
- le truc plus logique donc première
partie c'est max qui s'est trompé
deuxième partie c'est digne ouais bah
c'est pas un peu la fin du monde c'est
pas comme mattila moins deux là c'est
pas oui mais c'est quand même trompé peu
importe
ouais je me bats dans mes souvenirs je
sais quel point des cats après comme je
joue plus trop en ce moment je révise
plus trop d'élus les fichiers c'est
quand tu fais plein de tournon à la
suite tu révises plein de trucs donc tu
te rappelles mieux là comme je joue pas
trop je ne me rappelle pas forcément
bien des fois et qui dit mais il reste
quand même bien digne ouais mais c'est
un peu la réussite c'est un peu la
réussite côté digue géré par la queue
maxime l'erreur qui fait il appel j'ai
pas envie dire pas de chance mais il n'a
pas de réussite que son intervention ait
lui coûte aussi cher tu peux tomber sur
une intervention une interversion ou
goûter à ok les blancs sont à +0 3 à +0
4 la maxime il s'est tapé l'inter
l'interversion où le mec et maykop de la
différence est gagnant et qui jouent
meloni elliot se joue québec 3b trois
noms se ruinant forcément je fais quoi
vais-je entraîne beaucoup en train de
plus ok donc ils ont rejoint la ligne de
l'autre jour non avec un v6 la ligne qui
nous plaisait pas du tout pour je
pensais juste que ça faisait un bon
quart d'heure pour les blancs ouais
c'est pas non plus ça reste une
structure solide mais comme manu sommes
beaucoup ces structures pour ça bizarre
de rentrer dedans volontairement 7 600
touristes
tu penses que les vols dans sa carrière
par exemple il ya encore des objectifs
ou pas ou maintenant il veut jouer des
tournois par ci par là mais la spat ne
pas se qualifier je pensais tu es dur
pour ces postes impression pas compris
le sens de ma question c'est est-ce que
comme il a raté les candidats fils
encore will ouais c'est ça bizarre la
pause chiroque s'il ya vraiment là et
blanc veut mettre un camion décade mais
bon les normes quand je fus c5 ou pire
autour c4 ses soins beaucoup autour
c'est simple si je suis enfin c'est un
genre de française dual pions des cas
qui a disparu il ya plus de fous de
quatre planches pour les noirs et
qu'elle en fait c'est une quarantaine d'
avance 5 où ils peuvent beaucoup des
chambres donc je dirais plutôt ok point
mort visuellement c'est lorsque magnus
ce dès qu'ils commencent à perdre à perd
confiance à s'agacer tous à son niveau
de jeu ils baissent cammas est
drastiquement bas il joue tellement bien
le reste du temps que ça il a joué tu
avais faut penser suspect donc là ces
dames ce2 plus malins cachent trois
parce que sinon il faut 17 donc dame ces
deux comme ça fout première 3 c'est beau
mais c'est sans kaka et b5
on est dans le tempo pour tempo près
il n'a pas bonne presse à on aime
beaucoup le frère 6
on est les rois du pétrole on peut faire
même peut-être un karelia muel
d'insurgés a3 près de kiev 4 5
oui il ya aussi torcéen simplement raté
son coup mesdames ces deux il va le
trouver maxime c'est le coup de plus
logique en fait tu tapes c6 donc
probablement fouet f3 pour des vieilles
cavaliers on a un petit avantage long
terme
ouais ça tu peux la joie ce jeu
peut-être qu'avec up tu fonces au regard
figé cinq mérités six coups de jets 3 je
ne sais pas ce que ton cul du web
peut-être jeu mettra le ranger deux
sérieusement
d'après tour des intrants qui l'a fait
quoi maxime down the way non c'est ok il
a senti plus 80 cents à 112 j'allais
peut y croire quand même mieux si la
joue un truc intéressant je regarde la
cama il a il a pas laissé partir ses 4
il a fait trois quatre trophées cup s
500 ça paraît tellement qu'ils posent
qui fait quand même alors son carillon y
en a rien à faire now j'aime bien non
mais au moins ça ne dérangerait pas non
plus devant les blancs sont pas la voir
ça à l'air frais même un petit pot son
truc c'est à hem pipeau c'est ce que tu
prends pions fou problème est fou prends
moi c'est la partie il te dit qu'il va
faire voir un tir ok intitie faut pas
prendre ça ressemble vraiment une
française qui a mal tourné un fort mal
tourné pas super mal tourné mais qui toi
tu serais moyens ou pas après eux cinq
n'a pas trop envie de jeu puisque des 5
sera faible
il blanc veulent joutes auront un ouais
c'est clair
amine bizarre conclusion du blizzard sur
maxime a bien sûr à médine il va être
obligé de faire [ __ ] un écran maxime
qui peut tu vois ça peut partir de là
franchement les mecs on est confiant là
et surtout lot et pas dans sa zone
concevoir un jeu tout impôt après faut
que maxime il est il est encore la
motive de gagner le match quoi il ya
aussi ça être menées comme ça est ce
qu'il peut avoir envie de lâcher le
match et de se concentrer sur jérusalem
moyenne ses comptes de lâcher le mal
parce que enfin c'est juste la tan a
rejoué de boulot tu as tout donné toute
l'année pour ce truc qui te reste un
jour fait le à fond et après dans tous
les 4 3
il faut qu'ils jugent normal mais
peut-être qu'ils vous prenait froid et à
emi peuvent de ces cinq noms trois
cavaliers pros f3c 5 9 6 c'est juste à
tour c'est en effet même si c'est encore
plus fort donc peut-être jeu tour ses
huit avec le nom ici et a fait 3-3 donc
avalé prends ça va être joué c'est sur
un meuble chose sinon il abandonne ses
sinon c'est faire du streaming
ouais donc pour ces huit peut-être comme
ça sur comme sa c5 et le jour il ya dame
française dans une anse où la dame pari
fou proche de l'échec exactement mais
peu de tours ac 1-1 ont toujours ces
cinq-là à ok donc c'est peut-être ça qui
veut il a fait car il y eu 4 le coup
qu'on avait vu en premier donc c'est pas
du tout ce qui n'est pas sage et 3 pour
les blancs non en fait il faut quelqu es
peut-être que tu peux juste ours un
cabri g5 et e5 pour défendre h 2 sinon
menace avec les noirs cavalli price
trois échecs dames 3 2 il n'a pas
d'enjeu faux seins parce que ceux qui
prenaient trois tchèques mais mon idée
cf6 d'un processus
et sur tarn français six cavaliers prend
et surpris on prend le 5e dom français 7
c'était mon idée je pensais que j'avais
une tête de truc qui peut marcher donc
tour à ses 1 peut-être il devra faire
ses cinq tours fdn un tour à ses élites
tu auras des fous et 5 aussi qui vont
traîner il faudra vérifier
maxime qui a fait tous rêvent d un
attendent sur pied ses seins qui se
passe qu'est g5y se passe quoi du coup
cavaliers 5 à 6 6 et je vois pas la
pointer ici
non me fait qu'il prendrait 5 c'est plus
humain ah oui excuses désolé mais
remâche de sa échec échec
mesdames je devrais désolé non mais bon
l'autre option pouvais faire c'était
faux seins qui échangent et les fous est
joué
je répond j'aurais peut-être les choses
sont plus j'y pense et changer jouer et
puis on pendant combien de la loi
peuvent elles m'ont la concrètement tu
menaces flow sain il faut qu'on sait
c'est autour de 5
ouais tu va se prendre prendre dé
prendre en d5 à la fin avec le clouage
aux huit pilotes pour protéger fait tour
c'est 8
ok donc tu protèges aussi puisqu'il y
aura plus le clouage sur la colonne sait
pas le faire peut-être tour c'est
injuste pour renouveler la menace non ma
phrase pas vraiment ouais il pourra
reprendre de la tour est protégé des
cinq mais bon pour cent c'est quand même
très logique un nom là bon ménage et 3 1
c'est le coût normal donc avait déployé
sous roche 4 paraissent au noir c'est
noir de l'éducation joue comme ça on est
à près de tours siens elle a fait fou et
5ème au et donc du pilote il aurait pu
paraître un acte héroïque
on faire quoi faire dan à sion dame 17
et adam prend 1,4 c'était pas plus
logique de faire faut cinq ans quand
loeb devait reprendre de la dame ce que
la note va reprendre le bateau dont il
va est vrai mais il va ou avec la dame a
beau dire qu'il ya pas de bonnes cases
de la meuse 7
ouais mais peut-être dame pay2you moi je
pense qu'il va plutôt prendre les tours
siens à la maison tu forces plus ou
moins la prise parce que tu attaques
j'ai certes calme prises qui va les
prendre
cavaliers des fouilles pour revenir sur
détroit et si le pion avancé 5 ils vont
être 4 et on est content ok il peut la
gagner il a une très bonne technique
maxime non non non il n'a pas fait
d'amis b2 il a pris en recettes que j'ai
dit ouais tour c'est un cahier des cats
il al'air comment à la can et je sais
pas faux culs regardant tout cas la
position semble bien et il est ok ok il
ya du monde qui regarde oui bien sûr
weeding peut gagner les candidats ainsi
il a le sérieux pour après ça suffit
comme mary kay des cats
maxime jousse à l'invention qui va la
gagner c'est à la maxima dame b2 pas mal
des fois tu veux simplement jouer des
finales jordan 5
je vois pas je vois pas dit mieux
résister ici c'est quoi le temps c'est
vingt et quelques minutes cette vente
est une contre 16 non le match n'est pas
perdu et il gagne celle là il et il
pleuvait n'est vraiment en but mais
parce qu'il va il faut se relancer
donc l'idée c'est de mettre deux
cavaliers sur f4 et après tu pourras
jouer trois en fait f3 tu peux le jeu
surtout dans les finales quand échange
les dames tu peux jouer des coups comme
ça ça fait bien peu le roi mais là c'est
juste pour jouer r3 rêve deux donc c'est
très bien de changer d'homme on nous
demande pourquoi m vais aller mieux
parce que il ya deux pions c5 et dessins
qui sont deux cibles en réalité moi j'ai
les pieds pendant mes projets dynamiques
avec maintenant que j'ai mis la turbie
du comment pas du tout parce que moi je
mettrais quelque chose comme plus 07 08
la turbine mai 00
j'aurais 10h au trône un match que
j'aurais mis beaucoup plus non mais tu
sais jour ça doit tenir contre un ordi
acquis et noirci avec les banques qui
gagne jamais quand on en est mais en
pratique tu la joues comme moi j'ai
tellement l'impression que les que les
noirs sont dans le dur
non mais je suis assez bien par on ne
trouve pas qui joue vachement vite pour
ses rapides quand même eu un les deux
les deux titres sont magnus avant de
revenir pour moi finir ce qu'on va faire
que la finale après un ou là j'aurais
passe depuis le début contre chez manu
souvent et pourtant pour ceux qui
viennent d'arriver que son nom donne il
a rejoint son système où les sphères tb3
pour jouer en cas de gbagbo
donc les noirs leurs idées c'est sortir
le four et après j'ai eu six est venu ça
fait qu avait lieu 5
une idée logique mais à part et il
ajoute très bizarre il a fait un peu du
half à 00 h 4 h 5 après par la suite et
a4 a5 ouais il prendre du plomb sont
didier ses coulisses et sur la quatrième
dans peut-être que tour ces quatre
points ne ratez pas bête le 5 ans prend
cloud rock occitan hyper mise à mon la
partie intéressante même tour d un pet
ouais c'est ça ta meuf 7g venu 4 et
joueurs
donc tu peux
quatre noms que je crois qu'ils
indiquent est ton rêve de tour ashes 3,3
g 8 2 me jusque là qu'ils échangent les
dames très fins à 4 4 6 et tout reprend
6 dans lequel vous prendre les quatre
qui revient un an mais les blancs son
camion donc il veut payer des cats et
coupe tu as envie de jouer tout point f2
tampon à 6,3 g 8
on va montrer on peut pas apprendre
parce qu'on sur mater en deux pendant
est donc chargé ça qu'on veut on
renouvelle la menace de matt va me juger
3,1 en mai il peut je campe un échec
madame g 3g plus tôt attablé 3e dan g5
pardon non mais tu aurais fin d'année
d'un f4 savard transposer dans la finale
attendue reprend non mais c'est une
meilleure version tout reprend vas-y
3,28 mais on prend sur h
dames 1re cat reprendre cette première
vue parce que si tu faisais foulée c'est
tvtours oui oui
ouais donc voir ces il a joué ou pas si
je vais fouler je vais montrer quand
même hein mais avec dame prend ou tenant
g7 direct la gestion de prison je
voulais faire la force de miami auquel
je m'attends à calais des 4 après
peut-être qu'il veut jouer
[Musique]
enfin les blancs on va attendre qu'on
attende sur maxime allez vas-y vas-y
faut qu'il gagne cette finale donc avec
5 g 6 donc donc donc amené alpha zéro
c'est-à-dire pousser ses pions arias
parce qu'on a remarqué dans les parties
de golf à zéro il faisait très très
souvent ça pour créer des faiblesses
pour que pour avoir du jeu le sont les
grosses la grande diagonale et sur la
chronologie été très souvent ça donc
mathieu il fait b 4 ah ça c'est un coup
hyper responsable non c'est une hyper
logique stratégique man oui je veux
provoquer le purise orléans finale est
sûre c'est cathy décès qui veut jouer r3
mais quelques uns des cats
alors je ne sais pas dans quel ordre et
sur ses cadres du coup l importance et
qu'il est noir puissent pas venir avec
leur cahier en d3 sur français captaient
tenant sur ses cartes et aviatrice
sécateur du cavalier sapa et qu'on s'est
classé 8e mais tout reprend ses quatre
ça passe quand on sait qu as tu as l'air
dépassé 1 donc c'est juste à son idée et
surtour ses 8
la prison je ne veux pas faire des cinq
noms à bessens gaye cissé serait trop
besoin 9ème l'a6b tonnes précise que tu
attaques un pion qui va jouer f3 qui
nécessitent non non plus 24 hyper
intéressant marival a gagné 1,6 fait
sekkat il peut pas donc on est donc loin
d'être un peu mieux faire ce que dit le
redis il dit de faire ces quatre est ok
ce qu'on a raté tout reprend ses quatre
tours prend ses 4 et prend ses quatre
essais 3 1 euros
ouais tour des deux nominés nul mais qui
avait quatre tours détroit naias évite
aussi plus mal pour celui direct être
battant cavaliers à trois qu'il prend
1,2 et allumettes du couloir pour ceux
de wayne monkey tu vas premier donc qui
doit faire ses 4 ok f3 sont je crois
d'abord parce que qu'elle est décidée à
tourner sans relief 6-4 maintenant ouais
ça ça marche tant français 4 et français
quatre tours 8
trahis pas vu et on se sert de l pions
parce que tu vas voir un 2 contre 1 1
[Musique]
comment j'ai pas dans quel sens elle est
super gagnable en fait celle là ah ouais
faut pas tout à à 6,3 f2 tu laisses pas
pour à 3 vrai nom tu peux cliquer peux
tu peux gagner ça c'est même très
dangereux
3 oui me regardes et tu dis regarde la
partie c'est la variante est donc là on
nous ont poussés dans le g3 parce que
son dôme g5 se soit chaque et le truc
avec tour d'amérique at on a
l'impression que sa perche qui à tour à
la suite aux chutes
alors il donne plus à +51 donc c'est
fini j'ai juste etc et en mettant leurs
d'un coup on aime tout à l'heure on
avait regardé son ordi avec magnus qui
peut plier le match a quand même
laurenti dit qu'il ya une hot line qui
gagnent 2 qui avait lui aussi ce tout de
suite le tour à chute d'un homme jeu
trois jeux arcade
donc nous on avait dix tours à schwyz
qui est mieux quand même mais capello 6
gagne tout de suite logique
sept étrangers trois battues de la pièce
en fait c'est ça ok ok ok bon ça c'est
fini on est d'accord ok et maxime maxime
ça joue donc magus qui est en train de
plier le match avec six points d'écart
il y aura pas match là on est bien
d'accord et ont pu dire d'accord c'est
quand même ils vont il sait bien il
s'est bien relevée mais maxime maxime
bien favorisant la de cette partie ils
pourraient ils pourraient bien recollé
mathieu bien favori donc tour d'essai 8
on avait dit quoi finalement des 5 ou
comprends mais de l'eau les baies 5 g
pas pourquoi je le sens pas des quatre
peut-être goodman de couloir et si tu me
fais trois angélique et ses 300 millions
6 6 3 et si je fais puis on prend puis
on prend tout quand tu prends tout
reprend il à tour c'est un match ouais
et sinon je me la source s inquiètent
des saints qui viennent faiblesse donc
[Musique]
donc trouver des c'est donc ces quatre
peut-être un autour des c8 pardon c'est
80 de voir que ces batailles tour des
séries du coup avec l'idée sur b5 des
quatre mois que je pense qu'il faut
jouer trois cavaliers f6 donc il défend
des saints qui on joue on prend ces cinq
et on joue pour le rôle que c'est comme
ça commence et je progresse à vue là
c'est nul en fait la plus à ses pions la
tour défend latéralement elle vend à 5
tours b 1 on va la jouer on voit là je
tombe bien il ya tombé huit tours 17
tombes et l'asie
il va courir et on est tombé 5 y arriver
ça on va jouer jusqu'à 3h de ou g4
tomber cinq noms semblent plus loin
ouais la tour arrive sur à 50 mais ouais
pour ding et magnus baïla tout trouver
écoute il lui manque plus qu'à jouer qui
avait lui aussi sera essayé de le voir
en direct voilà c'est fini car il y
aussi jouer ses pièces de plus et ils
vont les vagues du bassin qui est
illégal fillon c'est mieux de gagner une
pièce on est d'accord
et puis regardez il reste vingt minutes
à la fin de la partie ainsi au delà il a
défoncé il a défoncé tu fais voir un peu
le chat fut un moment
ouais c'est quoi ce 13,3
ping qui est dans le dur non mais bon
c'est pas fini si ghezzal à un peu ça
peut nous annoncer des bisses de folie
il suffit qu'il en gagne deux de suite
on va tous y croire
il faut qu'il ya une salle est le
premier pit sent la bière ouais on y
croit et on y croit
moi aussi fait le saut s'offrait 13,9
situe à 13 7
oui mais si belle preuve oui ces galères
revivre ça serait 13,9
oui bon voilà on est complètement dans
le match après 1 c'est là qu'il faut
qu'il fasse il peut faire mieux
en trois ans et demi bref deux parties
en blitz accueillera quatre blitz
donc il ajoutant des c8 c'est le bon
coup oui ils rentrent dans cette finale
c'est à voir sinon ouais ahmed 11 ans la
vie de tourbe et un goût assez logique
elle est encore bien c'est logique après
des fois c'est pas bête de faire j'ai
quatre avant que le mec tu fasses h5
pour pas lui laisser fixer créatures
bien tu as quand même tournoi b 8h17 et
à 8 pour ça que je pensais que tu
reviens instable pelosi allez je pense
qu'elle est vraiment gagnable ans à la
non je regardais la cam bienvenus s'ils
regardent le regarda partie de maxime
vous dira gagnés d'affilée donc pourquoi
pas maxime cyril of you lapret béatse
genre de coup c'est des bons coups
stratégiques le principe des façons
simplifie un peu trop la pause mais la
pendule ses 15 contre 11
donc rien de spécial je pencherais
tordeur je mets une petite pause là une
petite pub ou le moment non mais si si
si si vraiment important j'ai une petite
plus elle se remettra que les seuls qui
l'ont pas bons tours b un tour c'est
cette couv et tournant d'antibes et 4
les quatre amis à thourotte y at il là
je tourne des deux est ce qu'avec les
noirs tu arrives plutôt le roi vert d66
même où est ce que tu vas plus tôt
angers7 caché réflexe gérant jacinthe
mais je sais pas si cette main tour d2
j'aime pas trop je trouve que c'est un
peu mou comme coup non basse-navarre
tourbe et un tour ces deux tours baby 3g
cet ours est tombé cette tare je vais
montrer devrait donc l'idée c'est ça
mais juste ça ça avait l'air très fort
donc tourbains empêché de corse et 2
donc pourquoi je veux tour d2 c'est pas
très précis enfin
moi on dirait une halte pique mes torts
berges france a vraiment simple après
peut-être qu'il veut ramener le roi du
genre après tomber intense et 7
ils pouvaient pas ramener le roi mais
même au pire tu faisais tourner b2c
vraiment aveugle où tu vas bizarrement
je rage aux gens je tombais un jeu 4
contre vous ou un truc du genre
alors comment est ce que les noirs
veulent avancer ici bas c'est un peu le
défaut de ces jeunes poissons point noir
ça devrait aller
mais le prince et que tu bouges plus
trop cavalier ouais tu peux aussi ne
m'attendais 6 mais c'est pas non plus
aux six mois j'avais m verts réussissent
pour essayer de mais quand tu feras des
quatre je te ferai e cat je mettrais un
camion de détroit était pas encore
également c'est pas évident à jouer à
quesnoy mais lui c'est toujours vous
avez à pour l'élan après j'y crois pas
je pense pas que ce soit suffisant en
partie longtemps
ouais mais bon on n'est pas parti longue
exactement c'est pour ça qu'on y croit
et magnus rivaux magnus qu'elle doit lui
faire rage cette île va être tout
échangé aux mets ses mots il pouvait pas
prendre le vent revient tant progiciel
vous comprends ouais j'suis il peut pas
arrêter le pion pour eux deux
aïe prouver il a raté sa bien joué un
bon bon bon ton coin trois qu'il avait
deux gamins enfin le truc c'est que
c'est tellement ceinturage cet échange
tout ici au 7e tour 7 est bon le jeu
comprend que tu fasses ça parce que tu
as et toutes les finales sont gagnantes
pascal plongée pas s'éloigner donc c'est
c'est qu'aulas le temps des porcs ces 25
minutes
ouais il va finir à plus de 20 minutes
mais ça aurait pas été du délai leur est
quasiment gagné du temps je pense sur la
partie est pas faux impressionnant dont
il a la playa trop la ramener le roi
vert e65 les noirs j'aurais fait h cinq
ans après les blancs pouvaient peut-être
arriver à juger 4
spy 2 après de ramener le roi aussi cédé
6-1 parce que tu couvres au moins ton
pions mais non c'était pas un blender
l'ombre de caves
ce qu'a fait ce qu'a fait michael n ya
pas qu elle et ses cinq as kasserine
prise pris un cap
parce que si tu échanges des cavaliers
je pense c'est vraiment nul
mais nous serine kébé c'est bien joué un
bloc la colonne et il protège le pion
les finales de cavaliers généralement
avec le plomb isolé sais rien joseph 4g
5 h 4 aussi est de créer un deuxième
front mais ouais j'aime pas trop ce
qu'il a fait avec ça tout retour des
deux tombés de haut
c'est un peu mou du genou a peut-être il
veut jeu qui a eu deux cas et des cats
mais lecavalier n'est jamais très bien
en d4
les blocs mais ils achètent en bessin et
loris tu peut pas essayer de faire tour
ses cinq tours à 5
justement si si mais c'est à bercy pour
faire le truc latéral tu feras tu toi 3d
fois et faire un quartier chic y aller
je commence à moins y croit
malheureusement je crois que c'est sur
un bouquin de devoir être ce qu'ils
avaient appris ça il te dis regarde les
pions faible est ce que tu veut attaquer
c'est de trouver la casse pour la tour
la mieux et genre la torah 5 ça paraît
vraiment une bonne qu as tu défends des
5 tu défends à cette attaque à deux dans
les bus ça on a aucun devoir est ce
qu'ils savent a vraiment beaucoup aidé
comme conseil je sais pas si tu es peu
mais ça c'est logique du moins je
connaissais pas mais hyper logique du
coup comme ça tu trouves une case et
puis après tu es la tour dessus et tu
fais un peu de tout quoi mon tour à st
bien je fus donc assez dur a déjà 00 m
on n'est pas surpris c'est la solution
qu'on avait voyons ding qui écrèment
impressionnant encore sur cette partie
parce qu'il est un peu moins bien la
sortie parce qu'il a il a pas plaint des
cats il a été un peu imprécis il allait
s'efforcer 6ème pseudo ouais mais mais
je veux dire après jalil a ce truc et
puis après pour défendre et la deux
vaut il est de nouveau prêt si comme
jamais quoi non mathieu il
m'impressionne dink basse et sa fenêtre
après le souhaitons lui d'être aussi en
forme aux candidats même c'est pas dit
hein c'est pas dit mais à mai mais bon
c'est pas ding la cam la chimie regarde
l'écran et dans l'île bizard
car look et xing futur champion du monde
écoute je ne sais pas mais met en effet
j'y croyais pas trop il ya un an et demi
wake là c'est bien correct mais là on
voit le gros progrès dans les rapides
nous étions on voit le ton sans le
talent vraiment et le bosseur ouais
ouais ça pue le travail ça pue le talent
c'est franchement il fait part qu'aider
qu'à 3 m6 jouer
moi je ferais h41 ou pour ces deux
d'abord les tours ces deux il va jouer
que je paye c'est que tu as peut-être a
ici une place 1 e 4 petits guesdon fra 4
honnêtement way pour faire g5 et
fourchette et un peu le roi et après il
va te faire caler ses 4 4 4 6 et 4 way
peut-être g5 je regardais avec 3 et 7
est ce que je peut sacrifier le pion
tourbe et sept tours à 2,3 g iii et
cavaliers aussi s'était créé un risotto
une façon tu t'attends tu es un
mais peut-être y fait roi ait fuité
cellule
as-tu fait retrouvé huit tours bessette
ne fait pas mieux ré regarder à chaque
fois joker5 watch is trois peut-être
peut-on th 6 allez s'il allait chercher
lui il faut qu'il fasse un truc comme ça
faut qu'ils créent et qu'il arrive à
trouver du jeu toi à lui faire peur au
moins je plonge cartilage 4 au moins lui
faire beau quoi
j'adore ce joueur mon goût il est pas
mauvais rila et c'est lui qui avait
éliminé à magnus il ya du monde
ashton peau bref 4-1 tu dis hein tu dis
deux ans on n'a pas trop le choix non
ouais mais du coup il n'y a plus de
réseau de mannequins très bien je suis
encore il du coup à cliquer ici cas si
tu doives le tour ces deux noms mais je
crois qu'il va falloir se rendre à
l'évidence e mathieu ça va pas le faire
hein ça va être dur 1 j crew potro tour
ces deux directs chavalit ckd j'imagine
et peut-être que faire rus/kat
maintenant ok sûrement l'idée je vais
10e 5
ce que t'as pas être 4g 4 qui traîne et
puis on me prend je fais tout reprend et
je te dis tu m'a enlevé ma seule
faiblesse
ouais mais si on fait pas ça on fait
quoi
c'est bof il a jeté ses 14 ans ding ding
qui va 4 et abbas et la partie et
cavalli ou 5 500 contrôles c6 miage ya
pas de g5 ya pas de tacles et j'ai envie
de te dire si tu continues avec les
blancs c'est même toi qui peux te
retrouver moins bien à force
bon c'est un peu la soupe à la grimace
c'est plus la soupe aux lentilles dire
si tu continues à vouloir la gagner
évidemment tu peux tu peux comme disent
les anglais bailout quoi mais maintenant
ils peuvent peut-être pas on sait ou pas
s'ils peuvent proposer je crois pas
qu'ils puissent je crois pas qu'il
puisse moi j'aime pas trop ces règles
vraiment d'interdire les nuls les
propositions non moi je pourrais je
pense quand je fais la france pendant
ces débiles qui servent qu'ils aient
remis la le droit de proposer avant le
30e qu'aux cdi annoncés je te dis pas de
patin je pense que tu dois l'autorisent
à partir du 40e par exemple ou du 32ème
du 30ème jeu juste à dire par là
intervient la proposition nul à 100% je
suis plutôt contre mais mais mais mais
mais là intervenir jusqu'à un certain
moment oui je suis d'accord avec toi
juste a certainement ça fait plus trop
sens bien joué et finalement tu offres
quel spectacle quand tu joues une
position complètement nulle pendant
vingt minutes pas sauf que toi francs
pierre spectacle c'est pire que rien
comme dérive laddh j'adore cette
expression c'est pire que rien il ajoute
on a quatre j'essaie de comprendre
l'inesss aude et 5,05 ou quoi ouais 5,6
et si bizarre kébé 5 ya des fourchettes
dû calculer mais il revient au dessin
québécismes a manqué bécistes attaque
attaque là hélas de 500 mille cavaliers
la salade chou à minuit la bière mais je
préférais cavagnoud 5 de ta part je
trouvais que c'était plus simple mais
bon après pour nous s'il ya des choses
qui sont sympas à nous enfin ils ont une
telle puissance de calcul que des trucs
en fait qui nous paraissent compliqués
pour son simple en réalité gfk sound
secteur et que maxime 5 pour moi mais
oui maintenant que je vois bien ça
marche juste parce que kbc double
attaque qui ont rayonné pions et du coup
c'est même peut-être même mieux sur le
cavalier sur des sens et à tour allait
très bien à 4 il ya jeu donc si je
prends un cut à qui il veut tomber
quatre des cinq petit piège et donc
pourquoi s'ils viennent pas c'est la
partie est à trois médias qui
intermédiaires et on n'a pas de coût
tour b2 pour faire
comme celle là bas rhin et la meuse
trois échecs intermédiaires et cavaliers
à 3 tours c'est un jouer au hockey
maxime qui se bat c'est bien pour ces 4
3 qui a et b 5 pour jouer le clou à
chaque arrêt des cinq pour ces quatre
jouer donc on attend 3 et l'autre va
faire un coup droit à une réussite
il n'est pas beau le cavalier 1,7 offert
wade 3 c'est un cavalier mevel ménages
aux cinq derniers tours des cats échec à
temps et sur f4f 4g rien non mes
raquettes c'est qu'elle contrôle avec le
mariage 3 pacs et l'élimination nada
mathieu wade 3 1 mais qui dit que je
manque d'anecdotes salaces arènes j'ose
pas trop d'où là c'est une c'est une
encyclopédie dont ben ça dépend anecdote
au négoce avec god save as we met fin à
ma femme elle est connue tu as peur
qu'on répète grave j'ai pas rater
d'avion ainsi si jeune et j'ai fait un
truc pas mal
après les olympiades à reykjavik
dans cette tâche pas d'europe derrière
l'équipe de france ça c'est pour séduire
et nous non pas une ambiance fantastique
et on était un peu dans le dur et d'un
espoir
petite soirée et j'étais pas même au
talent et à l'infini j'étais pas au même
hôtel que ma femme et je décide de faire
la sieste juste avant de prendre l'avion
je m'attends au pire la personne n'est
payé de l'équipe n'a fini sympa les mecs
et donc l'équipe de france on a des
compagnies aériennes aéroports et là il
va démonter
alors you mathieu en inquiètent ils
arrivent avec bacrot en taxi pas du tout
je dormais donc j'ai rater mon vol
reykjavik bordeaux paris et du coup je
me suis arrivé j'ai pris le taxi je suis
à l'aéroport
plus de 100 euros de taxi et j'ai trouvé
un reykjavik londres londres bordeaux
son côté 400 vols c'est là la raison
officielle tu faisais quoi en réalité
bush avait bu et je me sens dans mon dos
tres tres qu'on est un peu seulement une
bande dans l'avion à la stewart avait je
vais aux toilettes je me sens pas très
bien de l'ast voir il me dit ça va mal
mal désert ou alcool jeudi alcool n ai
jamais dit au quai à m'hamid arrière
très mal à son siège elle et je suis
resté avec les stewards derrière à
dormir il m'a porté à boire assez pour
ça c'était tranquille
j'étais bien il était heureux les
stewards dans le jeu je voyais j'étais
dans le dur donc sa part des tests année
là non mes parents en avril dernier on
avait fait une soirée avec elle je le
disais elle est là lui sain parce que je
faisais là elle est vraiment mignonne en
vrai ou pas ça va mais pas non plus haut
fin je l'avais aux olympiades ya 4 5 ans
m'avait pas du tout mais notre sérieux
même elle a l'air pas sain parce qu'elle
sourit le patron m'a fait ça va et du
coup dans les filles vraiment mignonne
en tournoi genre tu peux nous lâcher un
nom pas mais pas tant que ça mise à part
démente et bien sûr en deuxième position
derrière des ventes essieux pas 6 1 non
ça il ya pas beaucoup de monde là comme
ça ce qui saute aux yeux
du coup maxime officiellement perdu mais
ouais c'est là c'est la défaite adam et
j'ai envie de te dire mathieu
si à choisir entre ba dingli règne en
finale ou gagner au premier tour de ré
jérusalem on prend la balle est donc bon
là il ya une petite déception mais
maxime legros lynn onstot ouais mais un
peu jeune homme
enfin complet pour moi aussi se pique au
jeu la connaît déjà avec un en équipe ça
va il faut aimer les miniatures mais du
coup tu peux faire un t-shirt guy richer
jouer avec ta femme
c'est vrai j'ai joué mais aussi et c'est
plus marrant le t-shirt dirige déjà il
veut mais l'équipe de france sont pas si
l'on admirera et peut même pauline belle
jambe à l'entraîneur aussi oui du coup
on fait quoi on continue un peu ont su
même us où tu veux arrêter
toi tu le sens comment on va dire vous
le sentez comment moi je dis on fait un
straw poll et on voit si je te sans
vouloir suivre magnus non je sens que tu
as envie de suivre ma news sans mathieu
qui veut su manier les mecs n'ont
helmand quand même plus que ça mais là
mais le problème c'est qu'il ya 48 de
pause voilà c'est un peu car c'est à 18h
ouais ouais donc non c'est on est un peu
dans le dur non non je prends rhénan ya
trop de pause regard tout oppose
aujourd'hui on a un peu déprimé avec les
nations c'est la catastrophe avait elle
été un ressort pour elle et jérusalem
bonne question
c'est mardi je crois on
on verra bien bas en 40 minutes c'est
c'est un peu c'est un peu long je pense
on fait j'en suis le petit résumé vite
fait non ça fait beaucoup et 40 minutes
de plus et je pense pas qu'il soit un
jour est une étude déjà il a raison mais
n'en vaut mieux qu'on essaye de faire
jérusalem ce sera plus marrant c'est
bien de commenter jérusalem mais moi je
ferai les résumés nantes oh ouais mais
enfin peut-être qu'on va enfin je sais
juste pas comment ça va se passer mais
peut-être ya moyen de faire pas mal de
choses on verra mais les résumés ou un
tu me dira comment com en quoi et
comment on commençait à se fasse demi
finales finale ou vainqueur pour qu'ils
se qualifient bah ça dépend des autres
on fait donc ça dépend pas de lui à
ouais j'avais juste un petit truc a
demandé au chat aussi avant de partir
s'ils peuvent le faire en fait il ya
comment il s'appelle j'ai fermé le chat
ans je suis complètement débile juste
avant de partir mathieu vont partir
en fait j'ai re tweetent un truc et
j'aurais voulu que les gens mettent des
live sur notre temps fait il ya joueur
du grenier tu connais joueur du grenier
ou pas non pas du tout y'a joueur du
grenier qui a demandé qui a demandé ccd
plus gros chêne youtube n'a quand et du
coup il a demandé fin il faudrait faire
une vidéo pour recommander d'autres
chaînes de gaming nouveau pour faire de
la pub et il a demandé aux gens
4chan recommandé bon bah moi du coup
j'ai parlé de ma chaîne évidemment et du
coup ce serait cool que vous mettiez un
max de like histoire histoire de faire
monter le poste quoi je suis pas trop
dans les tweets chiffres là je me suis
mis pour toi fais rire j'avais pas
twitchell vente presse et twitter du
coup c'est encore autre chose
un twitter j'ai un truc mais je crois
que j'ai jamais posée
t'as jamais posté donc voilà si les gens
veulent filer un petit coup de main pour
avoir l'espoir que jdg regardent moins
la chaîne peut-être pas qu'ils en
parlent mais au moins qu'ils regardent
c'est vraiment une bonne chaîne jdg
franchement tu pourra regarder c'est
assez marrant c'est assez marrant et
notamment tu connais les missions les
dessous des cartes
non à rennes on regarde pas du tout les
mêmes choses mathieu c'est une émission
sur arte c'est sûr les jours où est
l'éthique des séries en fait tu regardes
netflix entre autres jeunes gens suit 1
145 série que j'ai suivi à wind enquête
c'est à dire que tu étais dans le turf
eu des séries quoi grave mais du coup là
je suis un peu dans le dur à remonter
les meubles et commenté j'ai regardé
moins de six rails là donc ce matin j'ai
comme faut regarder deux bombes a du
coup du coup si les gens elle finalement
beaucoup dj patou je suis très sérieuse
et très nouveautés aux échecs mais ça
c'est pas du coup mathieu on se retrouve
on se retrouve on se retrouve pour
tel-aviv à partir de mercredi je sais
pas si tu seras là six femmes ce camp là
je sais pas comment ça se passera les
résumés y aura tous moi je suis là tout
le temps mais t'as quoi tu es avec libye
tu es tout seul je sais pas en fait je
pense je ne sais rien fait tu demandes
comme de td ou va toujours
bah c'est pas moi qui décide en fait oui
c'est pour ça que j'imagine que tu
demandes pour ça que tu sois c'est pour
ça que je sais pas c'est vrai que c'est
pas eux
et du coup là le grand james moore qui
était pas prévu de base je sais je sais
pas comment je sais pas comment ils font
leurs trucs en fait si c'est toi qui
décide et serait plus simple je peux pas
dire je ferai il doit être content des
audiences que tu as eu comme c'était
super ouais non ils étaient ils étaient
super heureux d'ailleurs merci à tous
d'avoir suivi avec nous puisqu'on a été
on a été ultra ultra ultra nombreux on
est encore tu vois là même enfin de
trucs on est encore on est encore 1070
c'est pour te dire c'est pour te dire
donc c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
beaucoup et clairement
clairement c'est cool parce qu'on n'a
pas on n'a pas des caméras on n'a pas
grand chose donc vivement et hénin
non mais bon je vais au bout d'un moment
ça passe ça passe ça parle de soi même
il ya même rien besoin de dire donc on
va pas en dire plus mais du coup ça fait
vraiment plaisir que vous nous suiviez
et aussi à elle est résumée que tu as
fait mathieu que l'on fait avec toi ils
rencontrent vraiment un grand succès on
voit que les gens restent à fond sur les
vidéos ok mais cool non
oui maxime a perdu c'est pour ça qu'on
va arrêter on va pas faire les blues qui
commence dans 35 minutes même plus c'est
la deffe états d'âme
maxime qui repère en finale une nouvelle
fois et écoute vivement jérusalem fabien
reviendrai